And Rosa,
because then we won't get shit faced.
I told Joe and also it occurred to me
there's.
Joe Probably has all this other shit
he's not going to.
Wouldn't have.
We're live.
It's not my thing,
but I'm not an anti Rosie.
Drink a fucking peanut colada moment
present.
How to go in there.
You just enjoyed it,
right?
Yeah,
it was good.
I like it.
It's lovely time beverage.
Everybody likes some Jack Daniels.
It's single malt.
Chug this rosie first.
What does that even mean?
It's just in one of those barrels and
barrel to what?
You move it around a bunch.
Yeah.
You've Ribeiro that fucking shotgun.
I've listened to the Jimi Hendrix live
machine gun,
you know?
That's God damn.
That's,
that's one of those songs where
sometimes you hear it and you just go,
oh wow.
Like I've met.
Maybe been missing out on how good this
fucking song is there.
He's conjuring shit up out.
It's just so good.
You have that band of Gypsies record.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's all live.
I almost just stopped myself from saying
fuck.
And then I realized where we were just
thinking radio show.
Have we ever thought that one up on the
radio and the censored radio?
I don't know,
but there's this song called a power of
love,
so I just wanna keep talking about
Jimmy.
That's fucking insane.
I mean all this stuff's in saint,
but there's this tone that he hits that
just like carves a piece out of your
soul.
When I used to work with Phil Hartman,
he told me a story about when he was at
the whiskey and I think he was a
teenager,
still think phil was like 18 or 19 or
something and he was working as a stage
hand and his job was to hold up the
speaker while Jimmy Hendrix was onstage
because the stage was so small and the
speaker was kind of rocking,
so he had a stand there,
stand there and hold up the speaker and
he said,
Jimmy Hendrix was feet in front of me.
He said it was fucking incredible
tricks.
Was just sort of becoming Hendrix.
It'd be like 1966.
I could go back over when he died and
when he would have been like 18 or 19,
but I don't know.
She'd done 1970.
Really pretty sure.
Damn.
Look at you and Encyclopedia Britannica.
Hartman died in I think 98,
so whatever that was 20 years before
that.
There's.
This would have been like in the early
seventies I guess.
Yeah,
that doesn't make sense.
Actually.
I wish we could go back in time and
experience music like in the sixties and
seventies when it goes.
Just like everything was new.
He'd never heard anything like that
before.
Right.
It was the first time they got real
drugs.
Wait first time where the demonic chords
band.
We were talking about this the other
day,
like a long time back in the
renaissance.
16 hundreds.
There was corps.
They thought to evil.
They heard the shit we played today.
It would be like you'd be burned at the
stake because.
Oh yeah,
fuck that.
He would have been toast.
We'll just the beginning of Voodoo child
right now.
I never get sick of that.
But when you really stop and think about
like there was a.
There was a clear evolution,
right?
There was a bunch of shit going on.
There was chuck Berry and there was
little Richard and then there was elvis
and there was all these rock and roll
guys and then all the sudden there's
this eruption of that and it's led
Zepplin and it's the WHO and it's
hendricks and it's like people that were
just on a completely different level,
queen queen in their prime.
But it's interesting like they all were
driven.
Like Zeplin was all blues music.
They just stole a of Shit.
So a lot of shit that's fucked up,
isn't it?
It's fucked up that they are dicks about
it,
but it's not out of the ordinary because
all those dudes were just playing each
other's songs.
Anyway.
Dad is a giant problem.
If you're the guy who created the
opening riff to stairway to heaven,
it's about your song and when you try to
do with the other side of that spectrum
is really fucked up though too because
now you're in this game where like if
you play anything remotely sounds like
that you'll get sued.
And at this point like,
I mean I don't rip off songs from other
people.
We don't do that.
But like you could make,
you could write a song and then not know
that it had a similar thing,
similar melody and somebody could come
after you and that fucking blows.
We were just talking about that
bittersweet symphony song from the
verve.
How they gave all their money to the
rolling stones because the opening riff
was too similar.
Which is crazy.
They took a sample,
isn't it?
It's like this.
Yeah.
This is kind of Andrew Oldham produced
the stones and did all this
orchestrations for them and they just.
Oh,
they just said that.
How does that work though?
That seems kind of crazy that you give
all the money.
I don't.
I don't mind you give him the money.
I'm sure they didn't give all of it.
I mean they had publishing on their
actual song.
Is that different?
No,
the facts.
Is it different like as a musician,
do you feel like that feels different
with someone just uses like or like if
someone heard ice ice baby,
they knew it was under pressure.
Right?
I mean,
it's almost like it's not hurting your
original solid operation at that point
because your song was inspired by
another song and obviously there's
credit due for that,
but it's just an interesting way that
the pie gets cut up and the way people
just tenaciously hold onto their piece
in this way.
That I don't know.
It really bums me out to be.
I mean obviously you need to get paid
and make a living,
but inspirationally speaking,
it just.
The barometer is just so like people
just go so far off the chorus in order
to get credit and money for things that.
It's just bullshit,
but I think it's so different.
You were just talking about that in
there.
It's so difficult to have a career that
keeps paying you.
If anybody has something that's close to
the sun,
you're just like,
that's it because that's the only way
I'm going to be able to afford this
house.
The music business in particular or the.
I shouldn't say the music business
because I never really said the comedy
business.
I would say the comedy world,
because I think you guys are like the
closest to big business in the way,
like your contracts.
Are you always here?
Nike's nightmare contractual Jesus.
Like for us,
we've never made money doing anything
but performing,
so no one ever like got a grip of the
other stuff.
Right?
Like with musicians,
you guys all made a lot of money selling
actual albums back in the day.
Musicians that it could have folks to.
Right,
but I guess they always went through
record labels.
No money in it.
There was no.
I mean I should say like a few guys made
money,
like Dane Cook probably made a ton of
money because he had the biggest selling
comedy album of all time.
His was his,
at least platinum.
It might've went double platinum.
Do you get paid as an actor at that
point or is it.
Is it.
Well,
he must.
He must have had a deal with the record
company unless he released it
themselves.
Some people can release their stuff
themselves,
but I don't know.
This isn't live DVD.
Okay.
No,
but as soon as it gets to be a live DVD,
there's two options.
One is you could pay for it all
yourself,
pay for the filming and then sell it to
whatever organization,
whether it's Netflix or what have your
comedy central.
You could do it that way.
Okay.
What is this?
Both of them went platinum.
The platinum.
See,
that's,
that's a huge sales.
One million,
$215,000
and 1 million.
Two hundred or 264,000
for the second one.
That's incredible.
Like for a,
like a standup comedian to sell that
many albums.
He was a real.
He bought them for that.
Oh yeah.
That's funny.
I'm wondering what was number one?
Um,
I don't know.
That's a good question.
But theory,
US comedy number one and two.
Look,
he's right there.
Number one,
but at the time the second one read
this.
That's the highest I ever got was number
two.
Oh,
someone out peaked.
Old Chart Positions.
Live audio record.
So that was number one on the comedy
charts.
It was number one period.
What the fuck would say?
Number two,
his was number one.
Number four in the whole us chart
overall.
Wow,
that's crazy.
That's huge.
That's giant.
Um,
so that's it.
Like I didn't make shit.
I mean I made some money when I had a
record on warner brothers in 1999.
It was like a space monkey thing.
No,
that was called I'm going to be dead
someday.
That was my first thing.
And then.
And then uh,
the next one was a shiny happy jihad
that was Uhm,
and then talking monkeys and space.
We need to get our collection for the
road travels.
I'll hook you guys up.
How many albums you guys have?
No trace albums.
Tricks,
but we just were releasing solo records
this year,
so it's been like a really interesting,
like we're working together and
separately it's crazy.
You just keeping it together.
You get weird with each other all the
time,
but yeah.
Yeah.
But that is the way it is always.
It's always,
possibly,
always will be.
I feel like as long as everyone's kind,
it's unavoidable and it's part of the
process of dealing with people.
Well we get on each other's.
We definitely act like shit heads.
And then we have these moments of a
great communication.
That's the end goal.
But uh,
I think I can say that our relationship
has made my other relationships in my
life so much better because you have to
administer patients and listen and
really just have a target for people,
right?
Yeah.
Well you got to learn how to be wrong,
you know,
and say you're sorry when you fuck up.
Like I'm sorry I was,
I was wrong.
I was stupid of me.
I shouldn't have said that.
It's also there's a balancing act that
some people never achieve of listening
to someone and thinking about what
they're saying and then responding
because of that or just saying what's on
your mind.
Like there's this balancing act.
Sometimes you just want to say what's on
your mind and sometimes you have to like
absorb what this person is saying to you
and then you have to respect it and
address it and try to figure out how as
a person that cares about them,
what's the best way to get out what
you're thinking.
Sometimes you don't do that.
Then you have to deal with emotions
happening at the same goddamn which
completely changed the way you can speak
something that I got to.
I got a great therapist,
I love her so much and she,
you know,
accepting people is a huge deal and just
saying,
hey,
you and I have very different truths or
like,
you know,
not you and I,
but for anyone and when you're arguing
with somebody or you're in disagreement,
what is true to them could be completely
different to you,
but you know the,
if you just fight that and keep fighting
that you're going to be so fucked and,
and like there's no,
there's no piece involved in,
in that scenario.
So just like accepting your differences
is,
is half the battle.
How do we relay your message to the rest
of the world and solve that problem,
the world's worlds in conflict or how to
say you're sorry,
learn how to be wrong and then,
and then listen to each other for crying
out loud.
I think that's so important.
I feel like people want to be right when
you politics right now are just such a
shit show.
And if I try to stay on board,
I just get so exhausted because it's
never ending.
There's no,
there's no moment of,
of peace.
It's like,
okay,
now I'm going to,
I'm going to Piss,
now you're going to piss now I'm in a
piss and we're just going to keep
pissing.
And it just doesn't like I don't,
I don't,
I'm,
I'm really
annoyed with all of that.
I can't stand it.
Did you see what that Shit Shit.
Poster Guy Baked Alaska did what he
puts.
He posted a tweet that uh,
somehow he was proud that the president
was shit posting because you know,
you know what the president did with
trump did.
He took that?
Me and him slamming the guy with the CNN
had this baked Alaska guy who's like a
famous shit poster.
Do you know what shit posters they say,
look ridiculous shit.
And their memes and they fuck with
people and to get people upset.
It was pretty funny story.
I'm so honored to present his shit
posting on twitter.
It really makes the world a better
place.
Hilarious.
Alaska.
It's fucking funny,
man.
He had the funniest meme about Alex
Jones and I didn't know it was his and I
posted it on my instagram.
Somebody sent it to me.
I didn't know who it was and they posted
it and then he got mad at me and he said
it was stealing jokes,
but if I don't it was his.
It definitely would have given them
credit,
but the meme is hilarious.
It's hot.
It's him in the hot tub,
but what's the one with Alex Jones in
the hot tub when everybody wants to
chill,
but you're so woke.
You can't help drop truth bombs.
It's Alex Jones in a hot tub with
sunglasses on.
Just such a perfect meme for Alex.
that's a real art form.
The funny meme.
It really is,
and it's not there.
They're getting fucked.
You want to talk about people getting
fucked?
The creators of the funny meme.
I feel like there it is.
People try to relax,
but you're still.
You just have to drop another truth
bomb.
Really Fun.
Glasses on.
I love here.
Read.
Oh yeah.
Well that might be a filter.
Instagram uses a lot of filters and make
you look unhealthy.
That's shaming with the meme stuff
though.
Now it's like if you start stealing
people's memes,
you're.
You're a target.
You become.
Well yeah,
but the problem is a lot of people are
still not aware.
Like there's a lot of people that have
become famous because they have websites
and their pages get millions and
millions and millions of followers and
all they're doing is stealing people's
feelings.
Right.
And some of them have been forced to
credit people and some of them just sort
of like that fat Jewish guy.
He just sorta writes the person who
created it.
It's name in the,
the,
the big trouble trouble.
Yeah.
He got caught.
But I mean this is what West you don't
in my book,
but it's the,
it's the wild west.
I mean,
that's what it is.
It's like no one knew how.
I mean if you send me something and it's
really hilarious,
you know?
And then like Eddie,
Eddie Bravo just sent me one on bill
cosby.
I don't think I could share it.
It's fucked up enough.
I could show it to you,
but he sends it to me.
Ha.
I don't know who the fuck came up with
it.
You know,
it says you when you realize building a
wall,
fucks your quail food supply.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
He might've.
I have no idea.
Eddie does a lot of funny shit.
He might've made that himself.
But um,
I don't know who
made that,
you know what I mean?
So like when something like that
happens,
he sends it to me.
I might send it to Jamie.
Jamie sent it to Brendan.
Well,
when you make it.
Oh No,
he might've been.
It might've made.
That's my dreams,
but I'm,
the point is like how dare you,
how does someone mean so easy to make
one of those.
But it's a really funny joke.
Kind of someone like claim that there's
going to be like,
can you Kinda like a watermark or like,
that seems annoying though.
These are all the citizens,
but if you like,
if you like,
if you ben had a instagram page and you
started putting up those memes,
people steal them.
But if you've made your,
if you just decided,
you know what,
between as an exercise in between
writing songs,
I want to write some fucking joke man,
for a little bit.
Just to ground.
Yeah,
I don't.
I guess I just let it go.
I think I'd struggle with that.
That's a tough one.
Be An issue,
right?
You'd be like,
these motherfuckers already cooperating
other people's images anyway,
and a lot of the time your phrases and
stuff like that.
It's almost like collage when you got in
that little battle with a battle over
what mark man by the way will argue with
his own mom.
What happened?
He said something about.
He said,
I don't know why they picked me off.
He said memes are,
are,
are the kids who are about cultures of
vegetation saturates.
And I kind of send them this deep
breath.
You don't know because I was also
reading this other shit though.
I don't think you know exactly what it
means.
Sorry.
I jumped in.
Do it,
take it home.
What did you say?
No,
he said I sent back kind of like a
similarly bitchy thing because I was
reading about memes in a different
context.
I was like,
yes,
actually dealt with memes,
beans all the time,
mark,
and he was like,
I knew exactly what it means,
and I was like,
fuck,
that's really funny thing.
But then he went on,
it kind of drove it home.
He called me a poetry.
I was narrow minded minded because you
don't agree with his assessment of memes
because I went back at him.
I don't know what that means.
Narrow my friends and being like,
hey honey,
no,
you're great.
That was a great moment because Vernon
Reid from sprinkled in living color
chimed in and stood up and he was my
knight in shining.
I think we as human beings have to
resist names of the cancer cells,
the cultural imagination.
Oh God.
And by the way,
you know what I hate about it the most
no capital letter.
No period.
No,
can't do that.
We were on tour when it's cool man.
But sorry,
but you're wrong.
So I like,
I definitely can't claim any victory.
Pull over.
We had to pull over so we could figure
out what to do.
We'll have a cigarette holder if you're
writing that should have a black
turtleneck and a cigarette holder.
No Bull Shit.
Listening to you should be listening to
jazz if you wrote that.
Nothing to chance is great,
but there's some people that listen to
jazz just so people know.
They're listening to jazz.
Know that guy.
You know that guy.
So I just remembered there's this great.
You said Little Richard and Jimi Hendrix
before Jimi Hendrix was in little
Richard's band.
Do you know that?
Oh yeah.
I forgot about before he was.
Oh,
you know what?
He was this great [inaudible] interview
with Little Richard talking about Jimi
Hendrix.
Just high as a kite.
It's amazing.
And also,
how about Jerry Lee Lewis?
Jerry Lee Lewis fucking killed.
How many wives?
He said he made my toe go up my boot.
What heroin?
My Body.
The only property.
Ms.
Some people haven't been put the dip by
and pull back on the.
She's just a little.
Richard's amazing.
You got to be placed into the dipper and
pulled back down on the world and then
men would see your good works and
glorify God.
Jehovah,
Jimi Hendrix could play that rock and
roll,
be singing rock and get them to be gone
and he had that thing just romping and
dumping all up under my toes at times.
He
used to make my big toe shoot up in a
boot.
So good.
He gave it all to you and that's what
you want.
You want it all or none,
but pause this right here and to go on.
He didn't aspire to just be so fucking
fabulous that you are undeniable.
And Freddie Mercury.
We were talking about him earlier.
Have you seen those mid seventies shit
and it blows my mind because the dude
isn't.
He looks like Lord Far Quad,
but if that means anything to anybody
but he but he's tall and he's got to
skin tight white suit and his mid
seventies and he's gay and his Dick is
just like boom.
Like you could just see his.
If you did that,
now you'd be done.
You can't do that.
Can know who is up on stage with their
dick hanging out and it was literally,
you're just like,
oh,
there's this day.
Know like outside of his pants,
you're saying,
no,
you're doing a good job.
Clearly presented here.
Let me clear this up.
It doesn't need to be outside of a
transparent material stuck.
If,
if Justin timberlake did that,
it would be.
Just didn't do it.
See what happens.
Get those feet moving fast.
Some of us want to know that it was so
different than that.
People were somehow except pantyhose.
Like what is he got this like skin tight
body suit.
Right?
And what color is it?
White.
But how did it make you feel?
Your wife?
I was with.
So you're looking at his dick,
like as if he was wearing tight
underwear,
right?
It's beyond that.
You know what I'm saying about like what
about stuff like that?
Like what movie about people stripping.
This is a live concert in front of
people.
Anybody can fucking go.
And the dude's just like Bam.
It just shocked me,
Michelle and inspired.
Do you remember those old led Zeppelin
record released this fall?
Remember those old,
those old led Zepplin pictures where he
would have his hard tucked up on side of
his leg work.
You can't lie about that.
You can't fake that.
Everybody would know.
Yeah,
but when you wear underwear,
he doesn't show it that and he probably
got hard before the photo.
While you're young and of itself,
let alone an angel.
If you just put a rubber band around
your cock and balls,
go on and do it like that's insane.
That looks like that looks
uncomfortable.
Definitely was.
Definitely was you walk cock out.
Look at the one.
The white there.
Yeah,
he's Juba.
Jesus Christ.
So imagine that.
Imagine that.
But if you could see the outline there,
that'd be Freddie Mercury.
Then you know it's real.
Maybe all your problem put his dick to
the right and one way you can't really
change it.
Right?
What?
I'm right handed offensive.
You don't even have a penis.
You're offending me.
Want to know.
Show up.
If you were a girl and we were talking
about your vagina,
it would be really gross,
right?
We'd be like ask questions when you want
to know,
which is just right down the middle.
Symmetrical.
Every Robert Plant one is dick swinging
to the left.
Maybe it's that big.
He's got to Tuck it in a leg.
He's got to choose a leg and he's just
gotten comfortable.
He's got like a groove on the left side.
Toxins,
if you,
if you position yourself on stage a
certain way,
and I mean you guys all have dicks,
right?
So you don't allegedly,
but you don't wear pants is Robert
Plant.
So check me out.
Look at this.
What is going on here?
He's got his pants down.
Is that a scrotum?
It says Robert's last stand.
What is it?
Is that a real photo?
I don't think so.
That's a real blank one.
And then there was the real one that's
attached to it.
Encyclopedia Britannica.
Is that a real cover on that one?
You actually see his dick because I
would say the implication that I have
these moments when we're podcasting,
where I'm like,
God,
I hope my parents never listen to this.
They might,
they might really be into it.
I don't know.
What do you think then?
Well,
here's the thing.
I've been going through things with my
mom.
We don't really know each other that
well.
It's the truth and I feel like this.
She would learn a lot about me and my
life.
Oh my God,
that's heavy.
That's a lot.
Should we send it to her?
Definitely not.
No,
I think she could handle it.
That would be freaked out.
Sorry,
mom.
It's okay.
She,
she's a delicate person whenever.
I mean especially
in this day and age,
whenever.
Do you ever chance to sit and talk to
someone for three hours straight like
this?
It's rare.
This is sort of the cure for what ails
us when it comes to communicating like
podcast because there's.
It's so informal and it's really just
like sitting down talking,
which is what a lot of us don't ever
have the chance to do anymore.
Everyone is always doing a million
things.
You're always looking at your phone.
You're always about to go somewhere.
You got to meeting gotta this,
you gotta that.
When the fuck do you ever get three
hours?
Just sit to just sit and chill thing it
is and it seems to be here,
but isn't it crazy that just talking is
a special thing that shows you how weird
we are right now as human beings,
as an organism that grew up in a social
environment.
I mean every,
every person that survives that's alive
today comes from a history of people
that were in tribes were in these little
groups of people and social interaction
was everything.
But you had to know each show was being
alone and that doesn't happen very often
either when people.
Well,
I mean someone's Moody.
Come on.
No,
but you're talking about like devices
couldn't help myself.
I love you but your niche.
But it's true.
Like we know you're right.
We're always so busy.
There's always shit going on and like I
definitely have these moments where like
I wasn't just sitting not talking to
someone or looking at my phone like I
can't remember when I wasn't just
moving,
you know,
and not even meditating.
Just sitting.
I've become super aware lease over the
last year that there's a lot of wasted
time in looking at devices and computers
like I've.
I've been real aware of it to the point
where I had a way my bend,
the benefits of it are the benefits are
pretty numerous.
Like I get a lot of really interesting
articles off of social media and really
interesting articles that I find online
and really interesting up to date
information about space and science.
That's very,
very valuable to me,
but then there's also a lot of scrolling
constantly.
It's equally as fruitful as it is
beguiling because you'll get fucked up
and lost in it and like I wanted to
invent this app that I think someone
probably already did it,
but that puts a lock on your social
media so you only get like 20 minutes a
day and once it's done it's done.
They have those.
Yeah.
I mean I don't want it.
You just want to develop some,
but it's also crucial for our careers,
like it's crucial to your.
Your thing is built on social.
Yes.
It's crazy.
The thing is though,
you'd need time alone where your board,
this is what I believe,
read a book.
I think you need time to just be able to
sit and think about something or do
something like practice something when
you're like,
I'm sure you guys are like this with
music,
right?
Where you don't practice or I'm really
envious of his discipline.
He practices his guitar every day.
I'm.
Yeah,
you got to.
It's like meditation.
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
I think that there's something to that
for that.
Some
people don't experience you put your
phone over there or shut it off or put
an airplane mode and just do your thing.
You know?
We know what's crazy about the practices
when you can separate,
because it's tough because I'll have
devices on my phone that helped me
practice.
I'll metronomes and being this stuff's
going up and the difference between when
I don't have my phone,
when I'm not communicating with the
social media world of texting,
whatever,
and when I do,
it's insane.
In 20 minutes it's like working out.
If you focus for 20 minutes,
it's going to replace three hours of
shitty working out.
Am I right about that?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
It's all about how much,
how deep you can go in,
you know,
just a cognitively.
But,
and,
and I think in general,
people were like coming to grips with
this now as I Connecticut because we
didn't fucking 10 years ago,
none of this stuff existed.
This is like fresh out the gate.
So we're trying to figure this out and
there's this dude.
You just see people paying more and more
attention.
Exactly what you're saying is this guy
that wrote a book called deep work and
it's going viral.
People are paying attention to this
guy's ideas that are exactly what we're
talking about.
You need to shut off social media
advice,
you know,
stuff input,
um,
and allow your brain to sink down deep.
And that's where real value comes from,
right?
The only way to access simple real value
where people don't even realize how it
will take over your life in your
relationships.
Well,
it's new.
It's too new.
It's.
So what is it like?
Shut up 1994 is the internet.
Right.
That's like the main spread of the
Internet.
Now remember when we had this,
you know,
uh,
and it was like be,
it was electric.
It wasn't email yet either.
It was just like,
what do you understand that this is only
like 10 years old.
That was with the iphones versus what?
Didn't they just go through the 10th
anniversary of the iphone?
That's when it started.
Yeah.
Before that there were no apps.
Okay.
So there's no apps,
there's no twitter,
no facebook on your phone.
The snake game where it goes,
it like you,
you just had arrows and this and you had
to get the snake through this maze.
Games?
No,
it was a thing.
Joe,
you really missed out.
Okay.
I'm sorry to tell you.
What was it called here?
Ten years.
Barter.
Yeah.
Jamie,
if you find that I swear to God,
you're like,
oh my God.
It was a,
it was a thing.
Oh my God.
Well,
we did our first round motor.
It has been a thing with us,
with us.
Puzzle are you take this little
character and you propel him with his
own farts,
with your space bar and your arrows and
you think it sounds stupid,
but you play your first game and you're
just laughing.
I love Neil degrasse Tyson and then he
has us talking about how you live your
truth.
This is actually something that brought
us a lot of joy to start demo level.
Seems like you play.
Did you play it online?
Get it,
get it,
get it.
Yet it got to get
some sound.
Listen,
I'm going to play puzzle Florida.
Jamie's going to operate the controls
and play puzzle for one day.
Challenge yourself a lot of fun.
I just don't think people.
Yeah,
used to the idea of being alone anymore
without these devices and that's only
been around for 10 years.
It's a lot of false comfort,
but I think there's also like,
there's all these different disorders
and things that they're coming up with,
like you know,
young kids and their identity with
instagram and how it reflects their self
worth and how many likes they get and
who liked their photos and like,
it's really scary.
It's really until today where they were
saying
the girls as early as nine years old and
then surgery to make their vaginas look
better.
That's not true.
Yes.
Really might have be making it up.
Just so talk.
Yeah.
I don't think it's in the daily mail so
it might be questionable,
but as parents what?
But I know that vagina surgeries like,
like aesthetic vagina surgeries are on
the rise.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean they didn't exist.
There was a trend when you would die
your pubes blue and put a be dazzled.
Just,
you know,
trying to surgery.
It's much talking about the same pipe.
This is the BBC guys.
Come on,
that can't be right.
No,
but that headline,
vaginal surgery sought by girls as young
as nine.
Let me.
Vagina is a crazy looking.
Okay,
but how.
here's the thing,
people get weird.
You're right,
but it's a lot harder to discriminate.
Sorry to interrupt you,
but I beg to differ to operate on a dick
than a vagina.
I don't fuck it.
I'm talking about are we really making
judgment calls here and what's more.
I really hope your mom doesn't listen to
one of these things that we know nothing
about is more difficult operating on
body parts.
Um,
how do you know like this
man,
like cnn just got busted for they get,
they fired a bunch of people for writing
some story about trump and Russia.
That wasn't true.
You hear about that.
People get like super over zealous
trying to make a story real when they
didn't do like all the background work
that was necessary.
And people go,
I think that's why trump can get away
with calling cnn fake news,
right?
Because they're doing children's,
whether they're doing desperado shit,
they're getting into that blurry area
where they're doing things that are a
little bit sensational,
a little sensationalism,
and they're trying to get people to pay
attention and the pedal.
We know that that's not the case here.
Like when you see somebody,
I'm sure women are getting vagina
surgeries,
we've heard of it,
we know it's a real thing.
So,
but when you see as early as nine,
like manifests an instant click bait
like that,
proud saying as young as nine that might
be worth fucking hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
Sure.
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm just kidding.
There's one case of
this,
they could point to that as a reference
and we'll see.
I absurdity of a young child,
uh,
someone,
anyone like looking at their vagina in
any kind of pleasurable way,
it's totally fucked up.
So why would a kid care about the
appearance of their vagina?
Do you know what I mean?
Like none of this makes sense.
Well,
exactly.
I mean,
what's even creepier as you cut baby
degree to make them look better for
Jesus.
I did that for Jews.
This dude chooses not to be too
vulnerable here.
The other day,
I,
for the first time in my life,
saw my circumcision scar.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
That's what that is.
How did it make you feel?
It was intense,
I was like,
someone cut my dick off doing it right
now a little bit as we're talking about
are cut and baby now with this contract,
17 to just slice and baby Dick's for no
reason.
So many things I want to say and I just
want to keep them to myself at this
point because I should.
Well,
if you want to Sam,
I feel like you don't want to keep them
do so I'm going to.
Is it about.
Is it about baby dicks?
Are circumcised unser?
What else is going on guys?
How's that?
That's fine.
You don't have to go.
I know where you're going.
You don't have to say a word,
but to turn it over it's an aesthetic
thing,
but just because you're used to it yet.
This is being broadcast and we're not
just hanging out,
stopped talking,
and then we would not have to think
about it over and over.
Just going to focus on my joe action
figure.
I mean how many,
how much?
If a BBC news article like that probably
gets like a million hits,
right?
Am I being maybe a lot of hits,
right.
So how much is that worth?
Like if you can guarantee 50 percent
more worth thousands of dollars.
Like how much do they get?
They get paid by the ads that are on
their website,
right on the computer and I'm like,
you know,
looking at something and then there's
those,
you know,
a fi kind of things.
Oh yeah.
And I click on them because I'm curious
and I just feel so bad about myself.
I just feel like such a piece of shit.
Like you should be doing something
better with your time Suzanne.
Then looking at,
you know,
the uh,
I don't know before and after pictures
of,
you know what I mean?
Like who those articles are.
Like having phone sex with a robot.
Yeah.
It's like you never get anything out of
it.
Just this weird like there's no,
there's no real,
it's not a real article.
Like,
like if you read like,
you know,
the 18 hot women from the eighties,
you should see them now and you know,
and you go through them and it's like
who's writing this?
Like no one is doing what,
who benefits from it.
I'm curious like just beyond the veil,
like what is the point they get to
someone to get paid for you clicking
that button?
Yeah,
100 percent directing traffic.
I hate that,
but it's the same shit.
I mean like why do people buy fucking
Doritos?
It's the same thing,
isn't it?
Yeah.
What do you hate about it though?
Because I want to use my time and energy
wisely and not wasted on things like
that because I'd rather like sit with my
phone off and my computer off or,
or learn something that is beneficial.
I think that's just wasteful.
That's junk food.
It is but.
So is Doritos but doritos tastes good.
Yeah.
But they have healthy doritos goes to
the shell is a Dorito they have that
one.
My favorite trip at three slash slash
five slash whole foods is like,
it's like a bean chip and it tastes like
Doritos and it's,
it's not uh,
wait a minute.
What's three 65 slash whole foods in
Glendale,
in California,
in the Los Angeles.
So it's like,
it's like a cheaper whole foods.
It's like the brand three,
65 when you go to whole foods,
like an outlet.
It's an outlet for the poor kids.
I didn't know what that was.
It's for everybody.
Yeah.
Jessie out there.
It's out there to check it out,
give it,
you know,
take it for a spin.
So what were you saying about it?
No,
but they have like these,
they have these chips being Rito,
substitute tastes like Doritos and I
fucking love them.
They are delicious.
You don't want thinks adorable.
Transfats are fucking terrible for you.
Right?
They're horrible.
And the government has decided to outlaw
trans fats in two years.
Interesting.
Ruthless diarrhea.
Just shallow going dive because of
obesity,
because you're addicted to sucking down
these things.
What am I going into the transplant in
Canada,
they have their Heinz Ketchup and we
have our Heinz Ketchup in the Canadian.
Heinz Ketchup does not have high
fructose corn syrup.
What does it have?
Sugar.
I don't know,
but it doesn't have high fructose corn
syrup because it's band.
It was.
It tasted differently and I liked it.
I'm not kidding.
I just.
I think that's interesting that like
right on the other side of this border,
they have better ketchup whether they
have better coca cola in Mexico,
they do use cane sugar.
That's true.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't really drink coca cola,
but it's just interesting what the FDA
approves in our country for the food
that we eat.
Fuck,
I don't give a shit.
Fuck.
All those government agencies are bunch
of puppets when it comes to diet and
exercise and what you're allowed to put
in cigarettes and what you're allowed to
put in all sorts of different drugs that
get past it is fucking bananas that
there were talking about Nevada just
became legal for marijuana.
It's fucking bananas.
How it took until 2017.
We're states finally started making
weed,
legal.
All people are dropping off left and
right from opiates pills.
Like there was a study that Dr Hart.
Is that his name?
It's on my,
um,
my twitter.
I tweeted it uh,
earlier today or last night,
but,
uh,
it was 93 percent of patients that have
pain preferred cannabis over opiods.
Sure.
That makes sense.
Opioids,
opioids,
opioids.
Opioids.
I can attest to that.
They of course,
I mean a menstrual cramps are
debilitating for some ladies.
I'll be honest and that's why I got my
weed license because it's,
it is night and day thing.
Well,
they feel comfortable.
They have,
they have depositories that you put in
your,
in your twinkle,
just no,
they don't get you.
I mean they get your,
they make this warm,
wonderful feeling in your belly.
That is the antithesis of writhing in
pain and being out of commission for a
day,
which happens every month.
I get one or two days where I'm just
down.
I'm in so much pain,
I can't,
I can't do anything and it's awful.
Uh,
but,
but weed has been the best thing that's
happened for that ailment.
Whereas you take Motrin and you can take
Motrin,
but it can give you a terrible song cake
because it's really bad.
It's really,
it's really bad for your liver and you
know,
and you're taking like,
just handfuls of mode training,
all those things.
Yeah.
It's the same thing,
but it's nonsteroidal,
antiinflammatories.
Those things are super bad for your
body.
But it's interesting that that's what
you would,
you would take as opposed to having weed
legal in all of its different medicinal
facets that can help you with.
Well,
the differences obviously there's a
psychoactive effect is probably unwanted
for a lot of people that take advil.
They just want to get rid of the
headache.
They don't want to trip.
They're fucking balls off CBDS to.
Yeah,
they're great,
they're great.
But apparently some people take cbds and
they experienced some sort of a
psychoactive effect.
I've talked to quite a few people that
say that I don't understand that maybe
they're getting stuff that's like weird,
probably got popped.
And I think that too.
I think some of the recipes,
like I've definitely gotten edibles that
were duds and you have to.
It's just like,
oh,
I think they,
they miss something,
you know,
it's still sort of like a primitive
market.
So I think a lot of the companies and
you see some of them like come in and
come out just like boom,
boom,
like new restaurants didn't make it.
Um,
I think there's definitely a search for
more reliable product in that regard,
but uh,
I'm,
we're all so,
so different.
Like um,
I know you will react to weeds,
so different.
Terrible.
Yeah.
You might feel like last time we talked,
you told me not to blow up your spot,
but at one point you took a thousand
milligrams.
Is that you have done that?
A couple of insane.
If I take 10 milligrams I'm fucked.
Yeah.
But I can't hang with Joey.
Joey Diaz will take a thousand and then
they'll eat 250 more in front of you and
let that story.
We were at Coachella and I accidentally
took a 25 milligram jolly rancher
because it was a hard candy.
You don't just bite it in half.
And my friends were like,
you took the whole thing.
And I was like,
yeah.
And I lost my mind watching radiohead.
This is years ago and coincidentally ran
into Clark Jr and I was
like,
I was like Carrie.
And I was like,
you're fine.
Like I was like,
okay,
just losing my mind.
And then we,
I found out he was super helpful.
But I told you that story,
Joe,
and you were like,
fuck that.
I'd take 25 milligrams,
go to the movies.
And I was like,
okay,
well you are very tough.
Well this is the point is there's no
consistency.
Like you get your 25 milligrams and it's
also a matter of how much take and how
often take it.
Yeah,
I definitely didn't say it like that.
You're so cool.
You check the tape gentlemen about it,
but you like to brag about how much they
could take me included,
like pitch.
I take that whole you journey journey
pussy.
Joey Diaz is a horrible person though.
Joey will take these Chiba Chews and
he'll take the ones that have 500
milligrams swap the package for one that
has 75 milligram to somebody.
He doesn't give a fuck.
And he'll laugh because he knows you're
going to live.
Everybody lives.
We had a friend because we had a friend
who said
he ate an edible and he slept for two,
for 24 hours.
We're not going to say who,
but we had a friend.
Right.
I don't remember what you're talking
about.
It was so high,
you know,
you know who I'm talking about.
No,
I don't,
but it's all right.
Okay.
Well a friend of yours had never had
weed before and someone gave him an
edible and he slept for like 24 hours
and woke up like an entire day later.
If you don't do it all the time,
if you're not used to it.
Yeah,
I felt more high on edibles then I have
like taking mushrooms,
but I didn't take that many mushrooms,
but it's a very intense psychoactive
experience.
When you take an edible,
it is obviously.
There's so many times,
I apologize in advance,
but your body produces something called
11 hydroxy metabolites process.
When thc is processed by your liver,
it's five times more psychoactive than
thc.
It's way different drug and it's not
psychoactive when you smoke it,
so like when you're smoking pot,
you're.
Your body's not producing the 11 hydroxy
metabolite,
but when you process it with your liver,
your body produces this intense
psychedelic drug like you can have when
you eat weed and then close your eyes.
You have some of the craziest fucking
visuals that match up there.
As long as you have enough,
they go up right up to everything.
They go right up to mushrooms.
They go,
you can have like these many dmt trips
if you.
I smoked DMT with weed once.
It was insane.
How about that?
It changed my life.
When did you.
It really is a couple of years ago and
the good friend of mine and I took one
hit and it was like zero to 100.
It was just like you exhale and then you
just take off.
And I mean I,
I'd never smoked dmt before and I'm very
sensitive to wheat.
So I was high for two,
three hours was so.
And at one point I was watching,
we were sitting on a balcony and I was
watching the street and it flipped into
like negative,
like a photograph,
like the colors changed.
You smoke the DMT and.
And how many minutes later is this
happening?
This was in about 10 minutes.
Okay.
So that was when it was most intense.
So you kept your eyes open?
Oh yeah.
Should I close my eyes?
Oh,
tell me how to do it.
Sounds like you took a small dose of you
took one hit.
No,
I took a couple heads,
but my first hit,
it was just like literally like,
it was like star wars when it just goes
into warp speed.
You're like,
like it was insane.
Dante's got a weird threshold thing that
happens and it's telling me every three
hits in.
What happened to something about three,
three hits in is when reality dissolves
for most people.
That's what they say.
Three hits.
And um,
if you took like one or two,
you get crazy visuals.
You get weird freaky stuff.
Oh yeah.
But you don't go to the alien dementia I
saw.
No,
I.
Yes,
I did.
I totally did.
What?
You took enough.
So did you close your eyes while you
were there or did you have them open?
Well,
it was nighttime so I could see the
stars.
And at one point I went completely deaf.
All the sound just went and I was
watching a moving street and I couldn't
hear anything.
It was intense.
How high up were you?
A.
Just a couple of stories to worried
about freaking out and trying to fly.
No,
no,
no.
I was.
I was on the,
on the ride.
Wait,
tell me more.
Fear the big fear.
It's like someone taking a psychedelic
balcony.
Like Bill Hicks used to have a bit about
that young man on acid thought he could
fly,
you know,
left to tragically to his death.
Oh,
that's what a tragedy.
He goes,
what a Dick still here?
what did he thought he could fly?
Why did he take off from the ground
first?
Because we just lost a moron.
That's awful.
Oh boys,
great.
And then he had a positive drug store,
which you never do here.
Yeah,
it is interesting.
You know,
I don't like to say that the news is
fake because it's not fake.
It's like they're doing the best they
can.
They vet themselves the best they can
and they definitely fuck up and
definitely people get ambitious,
but it is kind of interesting that they
only tell you like sanction things like
you're never going to see like a whole
Fox News article on the benefits of
psychedelic drugs.
And how it could change your
consciousness,
how Suzanne smoke pot with Duncan
trussell with dmt laced in it.
But it could be,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean take mushrooms with Duncan wants
though.
I'm sure it was amazing.
It was the first time I'd ever really
been high on mushrooms.
I saw my grandfather.
That's intense.
Yeah,
we should talk that.
Another time
I saw my grandfather once on weed.
I ate them that a bone in her dream.
And that dream was really intense and I
was talking to my grandfather.
It was really weird.
Like I hadn't seen him in forever,
you know,
he died when I was who I was in my
twenties.
And feel real.
Oh yeah.
Do you guys spend a lot of time
together?
Yeah,
we did.
he was,
um,
he used to take me fishing and stuff
like that.
He was a really nice guy and just,
uh,
took care of my grandmother for the
last,
like 12 years of her life.
She had a stroke and then he had to take
care of her for a long time.
She had an aneurism.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And I lived with them at that time
because I'd moved from Boston to New
York.
I never placed a stay,
so I live with my grandfather and my
grandmother in New Jersey and it was
super dark time.
But how old were you?
A 24.
Somewhere around then.
And it made me realize like really
intensely that this life does not last
like in then you have to really be
appreciative of health in your movement,
your ability to move and your ability to
experience things.
And it just seems so.
It seems like such a given and because
it's such a given and we get wrapped up
in so many different things,
it's easy,
super easy to lose touch with that to be
happy.
Like I was talking to a really good
friend of mine who's going through a
divorce and he started getting all
bummed out about it and this and that.
And I was like,
look man,
you are so lucky.
You're happy.
You're healthy.
You're alive.
You have a bunch of great friends.
Like you're going to be fine.
Like if this is all gonna,
be fine.
Like it's just like a little journey,
you're going to go through it and it's
all in like how you look at it,
how you approach this journey,
how are you going to come out of it on
the other end,
but being a young guy and living with my
grandmother when she was dying and my
grandfather,
we to take care of her and seeing the
bolt of them like struggle.
It was,
it was intense.
Can I ask you a question?
Sure.
When you feel like,
you know,
when you had this psychedelic experience
where you saw your grandfather like does
that to you,
is that like a real experience of him
being somewhere else in communicating
with you or.
It's probably just an ego trip.
It's probably just me thinking that I
can recreate my memory,
but it was what was interesting about as
the memories were so intense,
there were so realistic.
They were like my grandfather,
like he used to talk and like he used to
behave.
He was always a very,
very gentle man.
A very gentle guy with a very easy way
about him.
Like he was a.
It was a really interesting guy when he
was like that in the dream it was,
he was that guy and the dream who makes
sense to,
if you go through a really impactful
time,
it just digs those grooves deep,
I'm sure in your brain.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Wow.
And uh,
I had it once with Phil Hartman to
superintendents.
The Phil Hartman womb was super intense.
It was years after he died,
like maybe more than 10.
And in the dream he was,
I'm sitting in a lawn chair and somehow
or another he was telling me what life
was like after his wife had killed
himself or killed him and they killed
herself.
It was a really intense.
And I was like somehow or another I was
talking to him from this next stage of
existence,
but the next stage of existence,
it wasn't heaven and it wasn't the DMT
dimension.
It was like a picnic.
It was like there was a lawn and it was
like,
it was like bunch of people hanging out
and he had a.
It was just laughing and joking around
and being jovial about things.
And he was just talking about,
Oh yeah,
we talked about that,
like a human.
The wife after she shot him and killed
him,
he was like joking around in my dream.
But yeah,
we had that.
We had to have a conversation about
that.
It was like,
wow.
Was,
it was so crazy.
It was so intense because it was so
real.
It was him.
And um,
he fell backwards in his chair,
like laughing,
fell backwards.
Is Chair almost like a prat fall and
then he was gone and then the dream was
gone and then it just,
it all went away and I woke up because
it was so intense.
I woke up and I was like,
whoa.
That really felt like I was talking to
Phil.
Like it didn't feel like,
just a memory.
It really felt like I was talking to
Phil.
But again,
what is that?
Is that an ego trip?
Is that you imagine
memory stuff?
Um,
do you,
are you all in?
I'm in.
I'm in because I've had experience.
No,
I mean,
I think there's a lot of bullshit with.
You need to be skeptical from the
external people that try to tell you
stuff,
but I've definitely had people help me
understand what all that shit means when
I've had dreams like that with my
deceased relatives.
And they told me things and then they
happened in.
Yeah,
it could be your ego,
but I like,
I don't think that makes it a less
real though.
If it's your ego or your mind,
you know,
creating a scenario with a loved one or
whatever.
That's this.
I don't think that's less real than the
idea of this spirit reembody being,
um,
you know,
uh,
I dunno,
some sort of physical form or whatever.
I think it's both.
They're both kind of valid.
It's,
it's,
it's energy.
I think it's an exchange of energy and
we've definitely been in places where we
felt like not alone,
you know,
and we,
and we weren't high.
We were,
you know,
you have those moments where like,
your instincts and your intuition are
like aware of external things that you
can't see,
but you can feel and maybe maybe you can
see him.
I've seen a ghost.
His dress,
what you just said,
though,
there is a difference,
right?
There is a difference we can see because
you're one of them is your imagination
and one of them,
as you're talking to a gross,
there's a huge difference because one of
them that means go surreal or the other
one,
it just means your imagination is real,
which are absolutely a 100 percent aware
of,
right?
So we know people have ridiculous
imaginations.
They dream and imagine things
constantly.
So there is a big difference.
Share two of them because one of them,
one of them gives you a view into
mystical world that doesn't,
doesn't end in the eyes of science.
It doesn't seem to make sense,
right?
It doesn't seem to want exists.
If there's another world where people
can come back from the dead and talk to
you and have conversations with you,
but one of the arguments that I've
always used with psychedelic drugs is
that if you feel like in a in a
psychedelic experience,
you went to heaven and had a
conversation with God or you went to
another dimension and talk to the
infinite wisdom that controls the,
the,
the cells of the universe.
If you did do that or if you took the
drugs and felt like you did that,
it's the same experience.
I think that's the difference.
It's like I don't know if God's real and
I don't know what the fuck happens when
he takes psychedelic drugs,
but God damn it feels similar like it.
There's moments where you have intent,
psychedelic trips where you really do
believe you're in the presence of like
this pure wisdom and pure love that sees
you in a way that is undeniable.
You can't argue it.
Wait,
I don't know.
I think sometimes it's your ego.
Sometimes it's some weird shit in your
brain and sometimes I think it's real.
I think it's.
It's very complicated.
It is complicated.
My point is the same experience.
If you're talking to God or if you're
talking to your imagination that creates
this God.
It's for that brief moment.
In those 15 minutes.
It's the same experience and I don't
know if that's enough,
but that's something like,
I don't know what your.
Your old time on earth is just time,
right?
Your time on earth.
It's just you have a limited finite
amount.
He got 100 years.
If you're fucking super lucky guy,
good genes and that's a wrap,
right?
So this is just.
We have this whole time thing,
but during those 15 minutes,
which is a small amount of time,
but the whole life small during those 15
minutes,
you are absolutely experiencing
something divine.
Now is out in your imagination,
is that you finding some portal to
another dimension?
Is that the reason why your brain
produces these chemicals in the first
place is because we transitioned during
the time of death into this new realm?
Is that it?
But if he doesn't accept what divinity
is,
includes all of that stuff,
he gets to be both right?
We sure,
but I mean like there's a real problem
with defining something that you just
can't define.
Like the whole problem with psychedelic
trips.
I don't know,
like free.
I don't know if you guys feel this way.
For me it's always like whenever I tell
somebody about them,
like why even use words,
like the words don't work,
right?
The Not enough,
you're not enough.
You could scramble them together and
say,
okay,
perfect.
And screaming from the rooftops to it
can almost like demean the experience or
diminish.
Sorry.
Well that's where we're pushing against
the limits of language,
you know,
and that's why I think there's such a
wide
array of people's theories and beliefs
and thoughts and they're all valid
because we don't have,
there's no agreed upon language to say,
okay,
this is how we all feel and this is how
we're doing it.
Right?
You know,
it's similar,
it's just,
I always go back to music with this
stuff,
but there's a similar pathway and trend
in music where people are constantly
redefining the language of it and you
know,
there's a kind of a mainstream,
um,
openness to that are,
there isn't,
but the idea that the point is the
language is dynamic,
you know,
and it goes on to continuously try and
express something that's kind of
inexpressible and that's why it acts as
a magnet for people suck because they
say,
okay,
this is kind of our pathway of
experimentation to understand these
phenomena.
That makes sense.
It seems like the fast food of music a
little bit and then there's some more
obscure like restaurants off the beaten
path that you've never tasted anything
like that.
And they're developing the vocabulary
the most.
People like that fucking tastes gross.
I'm not eating a cricket,
you know what I mean?
But,
but in 50 years,
you know that that vocabulary kind of
seeps its way in if it's,
if it's value.
I always felt like,
I mean you guys are the musicians,
but I always felt like what music sort
of is almost like a vessel that the
artist filled with emotion and with like
passion and it's almost like it doesn't
even matter what the words are
sometimes.
Sometimes it does because those words
and the feeling behind them enhance the
song.
But like Voodoo child,
perfect example.
Like there's like a lot of the lyrics
are particularly profound.
Like the data was born.
Say the moon turned all the lyrics.
I just know the feeling.
Feel the song.
Yeah.
It's just about being a bad mother
fucker.
I was born a bad motherfucker,
bitch.
He was.
He wasn't lying and argue that staring
me in the eye.
They say that moving out of the night I
was born.
I mean that's not profound,
right?
But when you hear him say it with that
guitar behind it,
with those emotions,
it carries that song.
It's like,
yeah,
and what's,
what's profound is,
is the,
it's part of a lineage.
You know what I mean?
That's a proclamation and that's part of
blues music and as part of African music
and it's part of all this stuff.
You just like,
I'm a fucking man or woman or whatever.
I'm a human boom.
Here it is.
Yeah.
But it's more than that with him.
When he's saying he's,
he's a Voodoo child.
I mean he's basically claiming some
Robert Johnson type shit.
That night I was born,
the moon turned a fire red,
you know?
Did he write that song?
Are we certain who?
Buddhist.
I don't know who wrote it.
Like a watch watchtower,
right?
That's about.
Yeah.
But this,
you know,
cause he,
he,
his grandmother was a native American so
he has all this,
like there's two versions to this
version that's like the real bluesy
version of Voodoo child,
you know,
there's the Voodoo child,
slight return.
Then there's that other version which is
much more or much more guitar driven.
Yeah man.
Like he,
like guitar sounds is a perfect example.
Uh,
Gary Clark Jr is a perfect example.
Like when he came and played with you
guys on stage and I saw you guys
downtown a few months back.
Dude,
when he gets on stage,
his sound is Gary Clark Jr.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like you guys were saying in midnight
rider,
which was fucking amazing.
He just plug in.
No,
he.
Yeah,
he just took my guitar playing trading
dude.
But that sound is like a sound that you
instantly,
like stevie ray vaughn had it hendricks.
They'll get a sale.
You instantly recognize one of his
riffs.
Crazy.
How does someone do that?
Right?
Because it's talking about as far as the
vocabulary to say,
and maybe this happens in fighting.
I imagined it does,
you know,
people have technIques or whatever,
that they slowly turned into their own.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
And that's what makes them well in their
derivative of a lot of things have a lot
of different techniques.
So then you kind of have this like,
yeah,
at least for music,
I'll speak for myself.
I just feel like I have this like garble
of stuff that just when people are like,
what are,
what,
how would you describe your sound?
It's so awkward because you're Like,
I sound just like that.
you know?
There's really can't make it sound like
I can't do this.
It's like,
don't ask me that question.
What kind of,
what kind of comedy are you?
Joe rogen show last week where a guy
asked me to make him laugh.
Oh fuck that.
I said,
well,
that's ridiculous.
So when someone calls up on the phone,
they're saying,
are you like,
sing me a song?
it's really good.
Let's hear you sing.
it's humbling.
It's super humbling because it's like
sometimes we've.
Why's it humbling?
You're talking to a twat?
Well,
no,
you're talking to someone who doesn't
understand why they're being a twat.
Sure.
But like,
I don't know.
I feel like the need to even connect
with the twat sometimes just say,
hey,
yeah,
I'll sing for you.
If you don't like it,
that's fine.
I'll sing for you.
That's fine.
I'm not above that.
But that was my chair.
One more time.
I would tell you and rebecca.
That's weird.
That's where there's no need for
somebody to ask that question.
Well,
you know,
it's just lazy entertaining.
It's also that job of being like the
radio host is a tough fucking job.
You get three minutes to talk to someone
you never talked to you before and maybe
not so good at it.
And djs on radio stations
nowadays,
they're not even really djs anymore.
They don't kit the pick the fucking
songs.
Who the fuck lets you pick the songs?
One dude,
fuck that.
There's some big daddy's out there on
the radio.
There's like 10 stations across the
nation that are still public radio like
heaven and became a w.
Like it doesn't Jason Bentley,
like pick,
pick his yet.
But that's a unique thing.
Yeah.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like there's still some,
some people that are holding court.
It's like game of thrones just knocking
bitches out.
So I think it has to be small stations
were not.
A lot of people are paying attention
exactly because the big ones,
they need the money that's going to
dictate the platelets,
but that doesn't mean you still can't.
If,
if that part of your job as a dj is even
taken away,
then what is your fucking job to be
interesting on the air?
They can't do that.
Do you?
Um.
Do you know how they get ratings?
This is the most hilarious thing.
Or they did at least until recently,
they still do the arbitron shit.
Is that how they do the radio ratings?
The way they do it as a,
they hand out books and they asked
people to fill out the books.
Tell us what you were listening to and
when you were listening to it.
So what you,
what do you get?
You get the opinion of assholes that it
will fucking books.
Who's going to fill out that book?
They're going to give you that book and
he go,
what to do?
I'm not filling out this fucking radio
book isn't like a sorry.
No,
you,
it's like our first record had a single
called little toy gun and they would
that they were testing that.
I guess maybe it's different now.
I don't know.
They were calling people like potential
listeners,
kind of like a nielsen vibe a little and
they would play them a bunch of songs
and be like,
whoa,
what did you like it like literally over
the phone you'd hear like 20 seconds of
a song and you give it a thumbs up or
thumbs down and that's how you're
getting the ratings.
That's what defines whether our song was
successful
different.
Now though,
there's like it now,
now you've got internet radio that's
free so people don't have to pay for it.
They don't have to call in,
they just have to listen and that is
monitored through,
you know,
you can,
you can measure that through spotify or
pandora or apple music and like I,
I have a single out right now that came
out a month ago and it's really,
it's doing really well.
That's called.
It's called ghost into my bed and it's
doing better than I thought it would.
I had no idea that it would be like
jumping from playlist two playlist.
I um,
this is our,
you know,
we're doing solo
projects this year.
How much of a fucking bad.
But I,
I looked at it,
it came out June 1st.
I had like a couple hundred followers on
spotify and like that week I got like
10,000
and then like,
like the other week it was at like
37,000
followers.
I,
it,
it blew my mind and I,
I call,
I have a pr team that's,
you have a team.
We've got a team.
I've got a team.
Yeah,
because I want to own my music.
So I hired a publicist,
a distributor,
and you get your manufacturing and
that's really all you need is,
is
doing the fucking work.
Isn't that crazy?
To own your own shit.
You gotta hire a bunch of people because
record companies make you think that you
need them and you don't.
Some of them are great too.
WHat do they do now?
Like what's a,
what's a record company good for today?
It would depends.
If they're actually good at their job,
they're good at a fucking selling music,
but that's very rare and that's hard to
do for everybody.
It's a combination though because
obviously like if the music's not good
enough,
it's not gonna work.
And if it is great,
but there's,
there's so many different.
Um,
you know,
it's a labyrinth of.
Oh no,
we're going to lose them.
Here we go.
Ben is going to be all smiles.
Blake.
Cool.
He was great fun.
It was so funny.
When you start reading,
you're just say that money isn't like
fun.
Fun.
Wait,
is this a test?
I'm just saying we have it now.
It's on the internet.
You said it.
She said you're not funny.
We have a lot of fights on.
Ben gets stoned,
but I also love you and want you to be
happy.
It means a lot to me.
This is live,
right?
Ben's mom might wasn't there one day,
but.
No,
no.
But in terms of the,
the record companies and releasing
music,
they have.
I mean,
every artist is different.
Every approach is differeNt,
but I think what's interesting is
they're jobs are becoming more and more
obsolete because of the evolution of the
industry,
but don't they try and take a piece of
your music sales thing.
EverYthing in that concert sales,
they try to take a page.
It depends on the deal is really common,
right.
To take a piece of your concert sales,
which it seems kind of crazy.
The live music,
it depends on your position,
your situation.
Who was it that we had in what musician
with everlast was explaining was he know
surely from garbage.
I listened to that and it was incredible
and she.
She had a lot of really interesting
point.
Cool.
She's so cool.
She might be like one of the coolest
people or garbage and a.
Is it a hole forming at the.
At the bowl,
the bowl,
the documentary that.
So the courtney love killed kurt cobain.
I'd started to wash it with my mom and
dad.
There was a journal that they put out to
people,
reads journals with my parents bought
the book because I was such a huge fan
and I felt like shit.
I was like,
I should not be doing this.
I don't want to read this to channels
that do change the war.
That was another one.
Like that guy had a sound.
There was something going on,
you know,
when the lights out.
it's less dangerous.
I mean,
come on man.
It's not the words mean something to the
words,
but it's the way he's expressing those
words or joe.
So what's interesting about the icons of
the decades,
you know,
you get the sixties,
like come see.
So the fifties were like everything's
perfect.
We have the cleanest music and we have a
cookie cutter home and this is the life
and this is the husband.
And this was like
the generation after world war ii of
like,
everything's fine.
We're cool.
We just came back from war.
We're going to make a lot of babies.
Right,
okay.
The fifties and there's this like total
disillusionment of oh no,
it was more survival I think.
But then the sixties or like people
trying to feel more.
And that was when psychedelics were
coming into the fifties and elvis and
all this stuff that was up ending all
this.
But he,
he was pioneering that though.
That was late fifties,
right.
And then,
and then going into the sixties of
people like there's this dichotomy of
like,
you know,
the,
the people kind of experiencing other
areas of life that aren't this sanitized
version of society and Blossoming more
into the seventies of just like harder
rock,
you know,
think,
sonically speaking,
you know,
you're going into zeppelin and pink
floyd and cooper,
Alice Cooper.
I can't.
The eighties or interesting that the
glam of the eighties,
I can't really help me out with the
significance of what that meant to
people.
I think it was,
it was,
it kind of went back to a little more of
this like pristine version of people in
society.
I feel like,
well,
let me give you the clean version of
what will a lot of people believe
happened.
Drugs became illegal.
Okay.
1970,
sweeping drug legislation.
Zach to schedule one act from Richard
Nixon.
As soon as it became illegal to possess
anything,
whether it's marijuana,
which is illegal for a long time.
Mushrooms,
it was really hard to do drugs and you
just got this massive drop off in the
creativity of music in the eighties was
the anger,
right?
That was the product of,
of that disillusionment.
I grew up with reagan on tv and they
didn't want plastic.
They just wanted everything to be like
flannel and he wanted to rain everyday.
People needed that
truth.
They needed that reality in that
expression of.
No,
I don't.
I think we need so many different
things.
We always need love.
We always knew,
but I think right now we're So
complicated and,
and in our individual rights,
but all,
you know,
I don't know what people need so many
diffeRent things now.
You can't really say that it's.
I mean like,
I mean I'm saying,
I'm not saying you can't really say
that.
I'm saying like,
it's so hard to say people need loVe or
people need this or people need
education and people need because it's.
You can't really say that there's any
one group of people.
There's so many groups of people,
but I do think mean
it doesn't get pulled out of the.
Just the spiraling of the phones and the
stuff for social media and I think the
only things that get them out of that
are real inspiration and I think real
inspiration has a,
is the spectrum of that is very wide.
Whether it's just a folk song or it's
like you're at a club and it's got that
whole rhythm of electronic music and
you're just with a group of people and
you're having this like tribal
collective thing.
Cool.
I Think.
I think that that's why I feel like you
asked what people need.
I don't know.
Everyone needs something different and
no,
you totally,
you know,
and whatever that is,
I think it just needs to inspire them.
We just need to know as a group
recognize that we're all so fucking
different and we've got to stop trying
to fit everybody into these little
package.
Well,
that's like the pronouns of um.
Oh god,
uh,
Your friend from Canada.
He was just on the podcast.
Jordan peterson.
Very interesting stuff.
Very interesting.
Fascinating.
God.
Yes.
You know,
he's dealing with a lot of like really
weird political correct weirdness guys.
A very thoughtful guy,
very well spoken guy,
but people want you to follow their
guidelines for how you should think and
communicate and what you sort of accept
and what you should argue against or not
argue against and it becomes this weird
sort of control game that goes on and
that's what's happening with a lot of
people in this,
in this nation is fine nation right now.
People are realizing that they have
control over people,
so they're exerting that control almost
the same way as a person in power does
like.
Like one of the things that abraham
lincoln said,
it was really brilliant.
He said,
most men can overcome adversity.
I'm paraphrasing.
He said,
most men can overcome adversity.
If you really want to test.
To me,
I'd give them success.
Which I thought was really fascinating
for a lot of people like that are in big
positions of power,
like the president United States for
perfect example.
Like the.
The idea of him getting through that and
not falling apart his way.
Like you realize like what a bad
motherfuCker obama was.
Holy shit.
Look,
people have zero idea how good obama's
composure was to get through that entire
eight years in the white house without
one like really gross misstep socially.
RigHt.
He didn't have one that's,
that's.
I think there's a lot of people that
would probably disagree with that and I
wouldn't agree with them,
but that's,
I think that kind of ideological thing
though.
They do think that there was one thing
that he said he was joking around that
white horse,
white house press correspondents' dinner
about the jonas brothers and about a has
two words for them.
Uh,
I don't remember that it was something
about drones.
What's the word?
What was the big name for the drone?
There's like a name or another name for
that drone.
It was like a type of drone,
isn't there?
Didn't he say that to them?
To the jonas bRothers?
Yeah.
He's kinda like a name.
There's a name for one of the drones.
It's one of the things that he said and
it was like,
come on man,
you've killed like 84 percent civilians
with drones or the United States has
like to say to joke around
with someone who wants to date your
daughter.
Come on man.
Like what was the predator?
Predator after them if they are huge
fans,
2010 Boys don't get any ideas.
I have two words for you.
Predator drones.
You'll never see a comment that he's
joking around about killing people.
Do you know many people lost their
children to predator drones while he was
an office?
A lot.
A lot of those things.
They take a look.
The people that are trying to kill those
terrorists out there and the isis
members and all the different people
that are doing horrible things like
blowing up ariana grande concerts and
all that kind of shit.
I mean the people that are trying to
stop those people have an insanely
difficult job.
Don't get me wrong,
but when you're shooting missiles out of
robots,
you're killing mostly innocent people.
It's not like clothes.
It's not like half and half like they
kill half bad guys.
Good guys.
no,
they killed mostly good people.
Put it in then.
Oh,
sorry.
That's okay.
It,
it speaks more to the position of the
president is being a tough fucking
because you can't.
You can't be a comedian and a comedian
can say whatever the fuck and it's fine
because you're a comedian or whatever.
That would have better delivery.
I'm imagining coming a mile away to
adwords for you.
Oh,
they're going to be funny words.
He's just joking around about something
that's a.
It's dark,
you know?
It's like you'll never see it coming
like a lot of those people that died.
Thousands.
That's kind of fucked up.
If you were living in a country where
obama was the guy who made the call and
the missiles came from the drones and
killed your dad and you have to watch
him joke around about shooting missiles
at some kids that want to fuck your
pretty good daughters.
Whoa.
You know,
that's a.
We don't look at it that way because
we're over here,
but how can we like,
how can you process that level of a
variety?
That's a shitty word for it,
but like there's so much shit going on.
This is why all this social media is
happening because along with being a
distraction and a problem,
it's also helping us cope with the
degree of the world.
you know what I mean?
There's so many fucking people.
How,
how could you ever be sensitive to the,
to the entire situation while being an
authentic person.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
but I think this is what we were talking
about earlier of like trying to.
I mean that's the fucking smallest level
of like learn how to apologize,
but learn,
learn how to be different from each
other and also work together and know
that like we have different speeds and
different beliefs and have compassion
and I think that's where it's really
crazy to have so much exposure to the
global events and become desensitized to
them because there's so much stuff that
it eventually,
like you can't compute.
You can't process it,
but it doesn't.
I mean,
obviously there's,
there's no excuse for making jokes about
drones and killing people had to make
some jokes and some forum,
but no,
you're totally right.
There's too much Information.
You're getting news from $7 million,
putting it on one man when he.
He is not just one man,
but he is a group of people working
together,
but he has to speak for everyone and and
so does trump and so does whoever is
president and,
and that's really interesting is that I
think what has happened now with the
election of trump is that people are
becoming so much more aware that there's
an entire cabinet and congress and the
people that we elect,
that we choose are going to be part of
that entire team and it's,
it's really,
it's,
it's focusing people on politics in a
way it never has before.
Yeah,
it is.
Corruption in a weird way.
Like a real transparent.
Speaking of corruption,
and I talked to you about this guy.
I'm about a represent us and it's this
organization that I went to this meeting
and was really informed for the first
time.
I'd never really understood how people
in congress kind of came to be these,
um,
you know,
runners in these elections,
whereas it costs 40 to $60,000
a day to run for congress and that is
legal.
That's not illegal.
That's so crazy.
And uh,
josh silver,
I,
until I talk to you about him a little
bit,
uh,
started this organization and they're,
they're working on a long day anti
corruption bills so that anybody can run
some,
you know,
uh,
an incredibly over accomplished,
you know,
qual,
overqualified person from say columbia
or harvard or wherever in the world or
in the states who we elected.
Whereas these people that cost that much
money to run their,
they're controlled by the koch brothers
and all the major oil industries.
What are they spending the money on it
because that much a day.
That's just the game.
That's just transportation of
advertisement,
promotion and you don't qualify if you
don't,
if you don't play that game.
But here's the thing,
you can qualify,
like if you ran for senate or something,
you would be spending $60 for president.
You know what I mean?
That's what's interesting,
right?
I mean I.
Well it because you have a platform
already and people have platforms in the
world.
That's Donald Trump.
Did you know that when you have a
platform she run up for like stan hope
was running for president for awhile.
We had a friend that ran for president
while he was running for president is
that he couldn't do standup shows
anymore because if he was going to do
something on stage,
he would have.
If it was like a public
where people were coming to see him,
he would have to allot time for his
opponents.
Right.
And I was like,
what?
And he's like,
yeah.
He goes,
it's a crazy scam.
It's like you can most of the game.
Yeah.
There's a lot of like weird freaky old
school rules.
Back when people would stand on a
soapbox and scream out into a large
group of people.
Those rules still apply crazy.
But the thing is you can do,
you can still,
if you have 10 million people being
like,
that's a stupid rule or however many it
takes,
it'll change maybe.
But look,
it's still federally illegal to smoke
marijuana.
there's no reason why we did,
but the state legal,
but federally it's still illegal.
So it's not as simple as.
It's not as simple as like 10 million
people can say.
They don't want to take more totally
right.
Again,
that's the same day.
what's going to go on with our political
system.
It's like,
yeah,
it needs an Overhaul and yeah,
it needs to be changed.
Needs to be updated for the internet and
the 2017 world that we live in and we
need to figure out a better way to do
it.
We don't need the same sort of
representative government that we alwaYs
needed.
When you had to take a message from a
fucking horse travel,
the pricing is.
It's like if,
if you wAnna,
if you want that to change from the
ground up,
you're asking the people that are
currently in office to bet against
themselves to say,
hey,
let's make it illegal
behavior citizens is what you're asking,
right?
Stop thinking that they're better or
different than us and that's where it
becomes unfathomable.
Well,
they have.
They have to just like everybody else,
we all have to realize that we're all
the same thing and every,
there's,
there's no kings anymore and there
should be.
I mean edward snowden tweeted this the
other day that people couldn't at one
point in time couldn't imagine the idea
that one day there'd be no kings and
they're going to say that.
The same thing about presidents one day
and it's for sure going to happen.
The president or whoever runs for
congress or senate,
they have to come to an understanding
that they are no different than us just
because they're in positions of power.
They're not different.
We're all just people and that if you
have extra power over people and you
utilize it,
you should be ashamed of yourself.
You should feel horrible.
Like,
did you guys hear what chris christie
did?
The beach thing.
He closed down the beaches in New Jersey
and then vacation on the beaches with
his family.
they closed them down due to budget cuts
in the shirt on.
He had his shirt off,
but he got caught.
He got caught lying.
They asked him,
did you get any sun?
He said,
no,
I didn't get any sun in.
The pictures came out and he's like,
ha.
They said,
oh,
mr christie had a baseball hat on.
So he didn't get his son.
Like,
no,
that's not a loophole.
You were lying.
You're still in the sun.
You're not in a house.
If you're not in a house,
you're getting sun you.
This is a play on words.
Bullshit that's happening in the media
where it's like people are,
you know,
you don't.
They just circumvent around the truth or
whatever they're trying to say with just
just stupid rhetoric is so annoying.
I fucking hate it.
It's changing.
It's.
I don't know.
It's changing because if this was years
ago
that news wouldn't have gotten out or
there would have been ways to just like
crush that and there still are so true
though.
You're right,
but it's definitely changing.
Yeah.
There's a kind of a to many of you wish
to hide that stuff,
not just that.
I mean,
look what you're doing right now.
You're talking to millions of people I
guess,
and you signed that does help with that,
so you're saying it to millions of
people and then millions of people are
going to have similar conversations
because of that.
When you hear something interesting that
someone talks about,
you start talking about hair.
This interesting conversation really
made me think about something and then
that just wasn't even available 10 years
ago.
It wasn't available 20 years ago.
Like all the social media stuff,
all the,
whether it's youtube videos that people
can make or podcast that people can make
or whatever the fuck it is.
Blogs that people can write.
All of it is just information and that
flow of information has never been
greater.
It is an unstoppable river.
Now,
you know,
to the point where that's why that baked
Alaska dude was laughing like the
fucking president jumped into the river,
like he's in the crazy river putting up
memes and talking shit about people
joking around about some lady having a
fucking plastic surgery.
She had like a face lift.
And you said she was bleeding like,
do you believe that you believe that the
president is saying this,
move that movie?
Um,
uh,
luke wilson and idiocrasy idiocracy.
It's happening.
It is really happening.
Well,
it's for sure a bad system that no one
wants to join in.
Like if you're elon musk,
why the fuck would you want to be
president?
I can bang supermodels and build rocket
ships.
Boom.
Why do I want to know?
Do you know
about our car?
Do you know the funny story about our
touring vehicle?
I do not.
Oh,
it's great.
Drop it.
So,
uh,
oh my god.
Ben,
is it three years ago?
Yeah.
Twenty 15,
2015.
So in spring of 2015 we thought it would
be.
This is when we put punk kid up for a
donation so we could buy a car.
So we could tour and we didn't want to
buy a van because that's annoying.
Who wants a van?
And we ended up,
we were looking at [inaudible] and we
found a cadillac escalades.
Two thousand seven seas decided,
well they're all the same car ps four it
expeditions,
escalades navigators to whatever the
year.
They're the same,
same structure,
just different clothes and there was a
great deal on a cadillac escalades and
we had like good a lot of touring in
front of us and we bought it and we
were,
we bought it with 60,000
miles on it and it was in mint
condition,
which was really strange.
And like the used car salesman logan,
there's clearly no kids in the backseat.
There's no cheerios took between the
seats.
And so we ended up buying this car and
we were looking through the user manual
to like what does this button do in the
former owner registration fell out.
Swear to got elon musk and ben had this
great idea,
great idea to get him to design a tesco
laid for better economical touring.
But to put it into perspective though,
we did,
we bought it with 60,000
miles an hour.
It has like a 160,000
miles on it and that was just about a
little over two years ago.
Have you seen that shit?
He's going to do in California where he
bores holes under los angeles and makes
tunnels.
And you ride a sled through the tunnel?
I heard about it,
but I heard about briefly actually you.
You dropped down into this tunnel and
you go shoot you.
You don't drive your car.
Why?
John?
Jamie,
I'll pull it up.
You could see it.
So watch what happens timmy.
You pull up to this thing,
he's a wizard.
You pull up to this thing and it drops
you down to your car.
Yeah,
it drops you down.
You get your blood,
get in the queue and you dropped down.
And then you get on a sled your cars on
a sled so you're not driving anymore.
And your car can be on a Solar powered
sled too,
by the way.
But all the power we have in la from the
sun,
I mean it never stops being sunny out
of.
They wanted to make these giant solar
banks to power this thing.
I bet they could,
but there's a video of it,
like the idea of it,
the animated version of it.
So of course everyone in the street,
he's driving a tesla.
There's nothing but tesla's and an old
rotten shitty cars from the 60 pay more
to get on the sled to.
Yeah.
Otherwise you're one of those traffic.
So watch this,
you dropped down and then once you
dropped down,
you are in these tunnels that he's
building that are totally earthquake
proof.
Don't worry when they fill up with water
and kill you and your family,
don't sweat it.
Look after you.
Make sure you have your go bag ready.
Fan of is your oxygen mask on freeways.
I just need everybody to understand that
when the 1000 foot waves come,
you will not survive in these fucking
tubes.
They will fill up with water and you
will drown.
Joe,
I'm so scared of most likely that
tsunamis not common,
but if anyone.
This is insane.
That's a wrap.
No,
a lot of thumbs downs though.
Yeah,
because people are freaking out about
the ocean.
Well,
rIght next to the fucking ocean in the
ground moves.
So we shouldn't be flying cars,
flying cars that have batteries in the
front so they can hit each other.
So they're like,
repel,
repel.
You don't want to bump,
dude.
You want to repel like two magnets that.
Hold on.
I'm writing the device last night that
scared the bejesus out of me
was it?
It was,
um,
they were showing just,
you know,
technological intelligence to overtake
cars and control the computers in the
cars and just,
it was crazy.
It was just like a,
just hacking hacking into any kind of
car.
And I'm gonna I'm gonna,
shut you down and run you off this cliff
or I'm gonna fuck with you and make your
windows go up and down.
And It's crazy.
I mean,
I don't want to be scared.
I don't want to live with like,
oh god.
And I
try not to,
but that's fucking crazy.
Fucking crazy.
You know,
that journalists,
they think the big conspiracy theory is
that,
uh,
he was killed because they overtook the
controls of his car and slammed him into
a tree and made him go 120 miles an
hour.
He was his name,
michael.
Um,
he was a fan.
it was a famous journalist who wrote a
story in the rolling stones about a
general and it was,
he was embedded with them,
I believe it was in Iraq,
in Afghanistan.
And he was the dumb.
No,
no,
it wasn't about portrays.
It was another general,
but no,
no,
it,
there's a different general michael
hastings.
So he wrote this article about this
general in the general how to step down
because the general was joking around
about obama or somethIng like that.
And there was just some.
He got a little loose.
What does this close sitting foot.
So this apparently they tried to say
that he committed suicide and some
people believe he did commit suicide and
some people believe so she's just flying
down and just slammed into a tree and
his fucking car blows up.
I'm,
here's the thing though,
and this is like in the interest of full
disclosure,
they,
they apparently said that they found
amphetamines on him,
on his body,
right?
So that could mean that he was under the
influence of amphetamines.
What had happened,
or it could mean that he takes adderall
because a lot of journalists take
adderall,
so they found in his system,
it doesn't necessarily mean he was speed
it up when he was driving like a fucking
maniac because he was off the rails.
It could just easily have meant that he
uses adderall to get his workload done,
which a shitload of journalists do.
So it might not have been anything.
And we talked to people that are
experts.
Boy,
people that are experts that weigh in on
conspiracy car crash evidence.
They're weirdos.
It's hard to find like who's right and
who's wrong,
but some people said that the way the
car had a separate,
the way the engine had exploded and
launched itself from the car indicate
some sort of an explosion more.
It doesn't impact,
you know,
because it just all hit the hit the tree
and blew up all at once,
but again,
could be bullshit,
but it is fucked up because the guy
wrote a very,
he wrote a very scathing article about
this general and I made the general
retire and I know that guy got a shit
ton of death threats and he was telling
everybody that if somebody kills me,
like be be sure that I didn't kill
myself.
Fuck,
that's crazy.
They can take over your car because your
car is a computer.
Your car.
A lot of cars today are connected to the
internet through wifi.
A lot of cars,
like they,
they have their own wifi hub.
Like you buy a new escalate,
it comes with a wifi hubs.
All the people in the car can play on
their ipads or whatever while you drive
and you link up to the internet.
That's on the um,
on the actual car itself,
that's a computer.
It's a computer.
It's connected to the net,
driving around,
you know,
somebody just gets
in there.
I mean there's,
there's no,
there's no bounds at this point.
How can you keep things organized?
Probably isn't the right way,
but how do you keep us all alive without
surrendering personal freedom?
LIke boom,
boom,
boom.
Like what?
Can we kind of have a crazy what's going
on with your question?
Just stop working on to see what the
deal was.
We don't have to talk about what you,
you know,
you don't,
you don't really have an answer to that
question because we don't even know what
they could really do right now.
One,
especially if part of the important
thing we need to accept is that we're
all the same thing,
then we have to accept that we all have
to start acting like the same thing at
the same time.
Right?
That's a,
that's a very good point.
but it gets lost when you start talking
about people that are in the military
and that are dealing with a national
emergencies or national security
situations.
But when you make a general retire
because you um,
you chose to write an article about some
things that you heard him say that it
gets him fired and then somehow or
another the military becomes compromised
because it's very important.
Leader is no longer in a position of
power.
That's a very tricky situation.
It's very tricky.
You did,
you dId get the scoop and you did get to
say how this guy was communicating,
you know,
candidly,
but things,
things are happening,
they're happening interdependently and
also completely and mess.
Like you can't mess the way that all
these things,
technology,
baba,
buzz is developing.
But there it is.
There's no way this dude,
they can control that much.
There's no way people can control where
this is going.
And by this I mean everything to that
degree.
So you just have to deal with all these
new phenomenon.
They're happening.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Look at this.
This is the article,
the runaway general to profile that
brought down mcchrystal rolling stone
profile of stanley mcchrystal that
changed history.
That's crazY.
That one article can get a general fire
change history and it's crazy.
The guy who wrote it is dead,
dead as fuck,
and they think dead from a crazy
conspiracy.
Michael hastings,
you know,
who the fuck knows it's,
but boy does it.
What's exciting is that the pit.
Wow.
So he's playing the general in this
movie,
he's playing a run,
a runaway general.
There's this netflix movie movie based
on rolling stone reporter michael
hastings.
Wow.
They're doing a movie based on that
thing happening for.
That's crazy,
isn't it?
IT's on netflix now.
Get the fuck out of here.
That's what it was about.
It's a netflix boding.
Yeah.
Dude.
Netflix almost has too much content.
It's overwhelming.
and it's funny because
there's so much content that,
that the quality's not that great.
So you get some shows in like,
I'll like this weekend I had this like
25 minutes in now and I just couldn't
fucking land on anything when were
trying to land on something,
something with substance and,
and just more um,
thought.
And I ended up watching Harry Potter
fire and I was so happy with my choice.
Okay.
All right.
Let me tell you something.
I've just started reading Harry Potter.
Harry potter is amazingly important.
Figures and let's be honest,
there's a lot of parallels to the
wizarding world and are fucking weird
world in politics.
There's politics in the wizarding world.
His word.
You guys ever go to the Harry Potter
ride at universal?
Not yet.
I haven't finished.
I want.
I'm a book and a half from finishing,
so I don't know what happened,
so fuck It up for me about the ride at
universal.
Yeah,
but I don't want to entertain.
Do you really think I know the plot?
Any of those clubs like you do and
you're displaying.
Here we go.
So then I.
So it's not decided who's just in the
back to.
Oh,
I'll drive here.
Give it to me.
I don't give a shit.
Do you have any proteIn bars?
Protein bars,
uber worry.
Not my friends.
We'll get through this with a steady
hand.
There is no concern,
but the Harry Potter ride at universal
is the shit.
It's really fun.
It's fucking crazy.
You've been in.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's fun.
It's really fun.
Does it feel.
I was telling you about this?
Maybe it's the same thing,
don't you get on a broom and it feels
like you're flying.
That's not a broom.
You're sitting in a chair,
but you're flying around.
Yeah.
Like you kind of would be if you were in
a broom.
Yeah,
there's a lot of stuff going on.
Just dragging and shit.
It's fun.
Oh my god.
It's really good ride.
It's like it's really well made.
You didn't understand this level of
excitement was the Harry Potter late
bloomer.
Okay.
I was all lord of the rings.
I read dune love dune.
Just like I'm a total nerd and I didn't
read Harry Potter and ben really
encouraged me this past year and he got
me the sorcerer's stone,
which is the first book and I just can't
and we don't have to.
It's amazing.
Like I can't,
I can't tell you how much joy it brought
me as an adult.
Yeah,
it's just,
here's the thing,
I think,
um,
I,
I feel like I have an affinity for like
fighting darkness just in myself because
I'm fucking dark,
but I'm also very light,
so,
you know,
as such is life and it's.
Yeah.
Here we go,
I'm going in,
but I folks listening at home,
they bought the last book,
the last book was the order of the
phoenix,
which is very political because there's,
there's,
you know,
a political presence,
there's the government,
excuse me,
within the wizarding community and it
was just really interesting to be
reading that while also like watching
our local news and our global news and
just it's,
it's all part of the same story in terms
of manipulation and what we interpret as
truth and it was,
it was just an interesting experience to
read that book and then to listen to
like my favorite podcasts and news
outlets and be like,
this isn't any different than Harry
Potter.
The familiarity of problems in human
nature.
Right.
It's all based on good and evil and fuck
ups and ego and power.
Latrolle battles.
Sheer value of j dot k dot rowling's.
Harry potter business is worth $25
billion.
Whoa.
Cool.
That seems like a lot.
She's,
she's rolling.
She's like willing to get married.
How does that,
how does that work?
I should say the joke.
A joke.
No,
I'm going to say no.
You guys know this is live,
right?
Don't argue over saving jokes.
Just say the fucking job.
Boom.
Better be good.
Oh my god.
You're not boxed.
We hotbox didn't even smoke.
Don't do it.
Let's just pull out.
We're about to hit the ocean.
Didn't Harry Potter get down the hill?
How?
Walking?
Jk rowling.
Solid.
I don't understand that.
It's okay.
We've got to bring up the joke.
I didn't come up with it.
I heard it.
Second hand.
Third hand rolling is the punchline of
the joke is also the author of the
famous Harry Potter.
No,
it's over.
This is a little rough delivery
delivery.
You said walking jk.
Jk meetings.
Just kidding.
It's okay.
I'm so glad you told that on joe's desk
jokes.
I love stupid jokes.
Get at me.
Hey,
tell me about this fucking crazy guitar
you guys have that somebody gave you.
Wound the national.
What happened?
What?
What happened with that guitar?
That thing's insane.
Beautiful guitar.
There's a company called national and
they thing is the same look and gave us
one because,
well I think they like us,
but they also like you,
I was a part of it.
We have to admit that I didn't do
anything but thank you.
Them they made.
That's
a crazy looking guitar that's not
normally taught resonator.
So it has.
I can't actually remember.
I think it has tricon resonators showing
the fact that you want to hear some
music.
Is that what you're getting?
No,
no.
I want to see that guitar.
That's,
that's it right there.
No,
that's not it.
But it's hard now.
I thought a guitar had to be made at of
wood.
I mean,
well this is technically a.
Well,
it's a different kind of guitar.
Some call them dobo definitely not
claiming any cone inside of.
I feel like I want ben here so I don't
look this up.
But um,
there's a resonator inside like a
speaker inside of see,
see how there's all this kind of mesh
look.
Will you go back up that one?
Yeah,
that.
Okay.
That's like a built in speaker and you
can plug them in so they're electric as
a speaker,
like a car speaker,
like a stereo speaker.
I'm not necessarily.
No,
I mean it's a.
Without electronics.
There's a cone inside is that the sound
resonates louder like a banjo kind of a
little bit.
But um,
so it's not like a,
like a stereo special.
I'm really sorry if I just put your
power,
the pitch.
Well jamie's a,
the actual audio
powered,
but it has a specific tone to it that
isn't like your,
your regular acoustic or electric guitar
and when you plug it in it sounds
amazing and it has sort of like a down
homey vibe and it's beautiful.
Not interesting down homey vibe like
down home me music,
like acoustic music is like down homie
music,
right?
Well,
um,
yeah,
I mean folk music and soul music or down
home,
resonator for guitar cover,
cover plate for biscuit.
Butchered the whole explanation of what
an nationalism.
She nailed it.
Okay.
So is there any word on that as the back
of that thing and the headstock and the
neck?
I'm going to pee,
but the body's metal.
That thing's insane looking man.
And so what kind of a different sound
does this thing make than a regular
guitar?
Wow.
So it's louder.
It cuts a lot more.
It's more resonant.
It's got a metal sound to it.
Yes,
sure.
So one,
if I had a slide.
These things are great for plants.
Slide with a because jamie,
what do you got?
A lighter?
Probably fucked it up,
but you can kind of wander around one or
a flat round,
but you can kind hear it.
Maybe sound like shit,
but you know what I mean.
Like some old school blue shit.
What does that.
There are some around.
Let's try that round cigar thing cohiba
whenever I hear that kind of shit.
I think of blues.
Yeah.
Because all that Robert Johnson stuff
slide all that.
He probably didn't have resonated
though.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a complaint site,
but it's a.
Are you with John Lee hooker?
Oh yeah.
My is he still around maybe 10 years
ago.
Like an eight because he was old.
He was playing when he's in his
nineties.
I didn't discover them until it was
probably in his eighties.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh,
he could.
You know what this is.
This will be big upside on.
Gary.
When I thought we said gary for the
first time,
he was just acoustic.
We played the show with him.
This was like 2011 or something and he
made me feel like John Lee hooker
because it was just him and there's this
hypnosis that he can kind of set over
you.
Yeah.
You know,
that's like a real blues.
That's where you get deeper into it.
These guys could really play that music.
It's the same thing.
John lee hooker.
You listened to it and you kind of like
in trance.
Jamie,
find my instagram where honey honey had
Gary Clark together on stage and you
guys are doing midnight rider.
I filmed a little bit of it and put it
up on instagram.
It was just so crazy.
I did everything that I hate people
doing a comedy clubs.
There's my hat.
Listen to Gary Clark lyrics,
but let me just explain this ass
off so much crap.
Know the words to this song.
They impromptu song live on stage in
front of all these people.
She had to check her phone for the
lyrics.
I had to block some dude who was being
such a fucking cock and I was like,
I'm sorry,
don't mention I'm not going to.
I tension.
Screw that dude.
But you know,
whatever shit happens,
you know,
it was such a fun night.
We did a song I didn't know and I wanted
to sing the words properly and I had to
look them up on my phone but thought I
was texting some dude and that wasn't
the case.
Thousands of people enjoyed that.
One or two were cons and you're focusing
on the wrong or.
Thank you joe.
Thank you.
So you've always been on social media,
yoda,
you know,
put out the right vibe and get the fuck
out of dodge and shit gets weird
getaway.
You don't try it.
You can't control and you definitely
can't argue with that.
Right?
And it's,
it is an effort to not care because I.
But you do care.
We should all care.
I just love people.
I really do like a really shitty person.
It's,
it's hard and I want to love that person
too,
I think,
but it's not about karen.
It's because you're going to care.
It's about recognizing what that person
is and then not letting him into your
house.
Agreed.
I agree.
You know what that is?
It's a dummy.
They just want to get mad about stuff.
Especially if you found out what it was
that you were just checking the lyrics
to a song that you'd never sang before
and was singing live with Gary Clark jr
in front of him and it was like midnight
in downtown la and some weird ass bar.
That was bad.
It makes me want to move to downtown la.
Live like batman,
so sort of a warehouse and have a
english dude.
Watch this shit over.
He's put boundaries on.
Happy to hear from the outside.
You don't know him,
man.
You might think you're unhappy.
All those musicians.
Fuck.
How do you feel like all the movies or
going into how bummed out he was all the
time because he can't share what he's
doing because secret.
Yeah,
exactly.
He needs a couple of good friends.
He can't get the validation.
Yeah.
He's got one old british friend and
funny.
He just needs more friends.
Yeah.
Like if I was batman,
I feel like I can tell you and you
wouldn't tell anybody.
You're absolutely right.
You already are batman because people
just didn't know.
Did you ever see that?
There was a.
Oh,
I guess I was actually comic book.
It was a a forgetful professor was a
professor and in the comic book this guy
was.
He was forgetful about all these
different things,
but he's like super genius professor and
at the end of the comic book he
recognized that he was actually an alien
from another planet come that came down
to earth to help us innovate,
but he forgot to jail for an alien from
another planet because you know it's
true.
You guys should do more of those weird
little downtown shows though.
We should shut.
Those were fun.
Those were.
That was so strange.
It was really fun.
Night,
midnight,
and it was so great because you were
there.
That's.
It was great.
What a great time.
It was awesome.
It was fun.
It was pretty fucking bad ass.
Yeah.
That was amazing.
Intimate shows are so big.
They're so,
you know,
like you
almost kind of have to do them.
Like if you just j lo,
the whole thing and you're on these big
gas giant stages for the rest of your
life.
Giants.
Even when I'm mad if she's doing
anything,
she's going to be like separated from
everybody.
Right.
The throwing couldn't close to rose
pedals that are feet and shit.
Yeah,
I mean I think that was as attractive to
that is.
Hold on.
There's the counterpoint is that
thought.
Seems like that's like the worst thing
that could ever happen to you because it
gets so separated for everybody that
you're like,
I'll put some giant ass stage and
everywhere you go you can interact with
people,
make all that Roger Waters last or two
weeks ago.
And it was incredible.
Tony,
when he said it was insane.
Oh my god.
And I think,
I think there's a.
Well,
I mean it's,
it's,
there's a reason that he's doing what
he's doing and people are coming to see
him because it's incredible and it's
authentic and it's raw and like that man
has obviously he has teams around him
that helped build that show.
He doesn't do that by himself,
but it was,
oh man,
it wasn't white rose pedals.
It was definitely a different thing.
That's a different thing.
Well,
not that fast food thing we were kind of
talking about earlier and I think
there's a place for that too.
Sometimes you're fucking starving and
you need something right now.
There's also like a lot of money in
being that icon,
that diva,
that thing,
you know,
it's like it's very attractive position
to try to attain.
It's almost like you just run a little
clue to close to the sun,
burn the wax off your waist,
and some of it's authentic in.
Some of it is totally.
You are a machine,
you are part of the manufactured
idealism that you represent and that is
a heavy burden.
I don't,
but you know,
it's probably not on anybody who
probably not enough.
Antick is people's ambition to get
there.
I think the people in those positions
are so fucking ravenous for that kind of
attention and that's the only way you
would possibly climb to the top of that
mountain.
You don't be fucking focused.
I think some people are are manipulated.
I don't know.
I think some people,
jackson,
I think some people have an idea of the
art and they're also exploited within
that realm because some parts of the
record industry are fucking insidious
and they take like.
Remember you were talking about that
documentary with these 15 year old kids
that were so talented,
but they were clearly just getting just
sucked into the thing.
You're too young,
you're too young to know what you're
doing.
There's just no if,
ands or buts about it.
In order to make the decision to be a
giant like Michael Jackson when we were
talking about jackson five earlier,
like when you sing an abc,
I mean he was a fucking baby.
He was baby baby and he was on tv.
You know,
he was on.
He was a huge star,
but also he had his family running the
show and it was like a really fucked up
dynamic and so it was almost like his.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
his talent was undeniable,
but like his family
were the record industry in that
respect.
Yeah.
Whose talent was so undeniable that he
was the youngest one and he got to sing.
Could you imagine you grew up with four
bad motherfuckers as brothers.
Your dad is a professional musician and
you are so good.
They're like,
okay,
let him say like everybody else wants to
want them to saying they all did their
solo projects afterwards.
They didn't say shit while michael had
the microphone.
Just like I'm saying,
I'm saying just let him sing and people
reacted to them real way.
Right?
I mean,
that's what,
oh man,
you know,
there's the exploitative aspect and then
it's like everybody want to fucking see
him sing.
I wish I saw him saying it was two
things,
right?
It was this emergence of this incredible
sound that came out of this one person
and all the different projects that he
was involved in and then it was also the
tragic,
almost like decimating of a potential
life because his life only existed so
strongly in the public eye that it
didn't exist anywhere else in the,
in a normal form outside.
It was just a chaos,
a mess of hanging out with kids and
weird relationships with women that
didn't seem real and living in an
amusement park.
It was just a mess.
It was just a total disaster.
Like everything outside of the magic
that he did in the public eye was just
hell.
It's really weird because what he did in
the public eye,
like thriller and beat it and all those
different things.
I mean they were so,
so intense.
Like I was in high school when all that
stuff was going on and I remember just
just watching like thriller on
television,
you know,
when they had the premiere,
the music video and everybody sat around
and watched thriller when it came out.
There's nothing like that ever ever.
It was crazy.
Like sorta like when hendrix came along,
there was nothing like that before.
Well,
when Michael Jackson came along,
there was nothing like that before
either.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Like someone had taken the whole thing
and put it into this totally new
package.
Whereas this feminine guy and he had one
glove on and he was dancing and
everybody wanted to move like,
um,
and I was like,
what in the fuck is
back to your,
like freddie mercury kinda dick out
thing.
It's like he did what he wanted to do
and he wasn't,
he was iconic because of it.
I think that's,
that's part of it.
It's like you just have to own it.
Well,
what he
did it on a level that was undeniable,
just like you talked about before,
because he,
because of his ambition,
it wasn't just I'm going to be me.
It was like I'm going gonna be me to the
furthest extent that I possibly fucking
can and this is what happened.
You know what I mean?
I have a friend who went to his house up
in los olivos and they went,
they toward his dance studio and he had
this private dance studio in this mirror
is against the wall and there's this
groove in the floor and this is,
you know,
he was later in his life at this point,
but he had worn out a part of the floor
from just practicing his shit.
Wow.
This is way beyond his teens and
twenties.
That's just who he was all the time.
You know,
people don't respect a song.
Dragon
attack,
attack.
I know the troll song ogre battle your
battle.
It's one of those songs to people for
god and he will play with the people on
youtube can hear it and we'll probably
have to.
We can play it for us though,
right?
We have to do some fancy editing,
probably control for everything.
We show a video of a caterpillar and we
get yanked off youtube the last time we.
We get yanked off youtube for stuff like
when,
when we put things on the air that are
on youtube that someone else has
listened to this.
This is.
This is dragging attack.
People don't.
They don't remember this.
Just think about.
Give me some volume.
Like come on math at dick's.
Just out.
Oh my god.
Come on mastic.
It's forgotten.
Classic.
You have to have.
Brian may gets better on your podcast.
Who?
Pick a time.
Dicks out out what?
Come on.
Get it feels so good.
All right.
We'll have to fade out here.
Gonna.
Have to face in trouble.
Come on.
Dragging.
Attack people.
Slept
on dragon attacks.
The queen's best songs.
it's just occurred to me right now.
What does that sound?
Do you hear that?
What does that check to see?
Does car.
This is the cigar feds.
It's the building.
Oh no,
I was there.
Fire alarm sound.
oh,
it's probably next door.
I was getting robbed.
Listen,
keep it together.
I've got to intervene.
Guys.
What kind of weapons do you have in this
place?
Oh,
we got joe rogan faces our human weapon.
Definitely not.
His bullets.
Codes are super hard to defend against.
Shit.
I saw her last night.
Baby driver.
Yeah.
You were saying earlier.
Everyone needs to see it.
That's what I keep hearing.
Incredible music and just a great story.
It's,
you guys hear that sound,
that sound.
A background is preventing us from
playing you beautiful harmonious music.
Well,
we just can't keep trying to ask him,
what do you want to ask?
If you have got to get brian me on your
podcast,
I would love to.
What's uh,
what's going on young jeremy.
Nobody's next door and the alarms going
off.
So this'll be going on forever.
We're moving into a rap song like nwa,
you know,
his like,
we can kind of just imagine that these
things have a time limit where they're
allowed to stay on.
I don't know about that.
The alert needs to find out fervent and.
Yeah.
But what happens when we weren't here?
So it goes back on and then the security
people have to come and what's next
door?
Is it worth checking out?
Boom.
No,
it's not anything exciting.
Bunch of shit.
I don't know what happened.
We might have to wrap this bitch up.
Can we talk through that?
Sure.
What's that?
Give me like a minute or two and I'll
see if there's someone out there that's
gonna unlock.
Okay.
Stop it soon,
but yeah,
when I was going to happen,
this could be one of our shortest pot.
Oh,
I don't know how long we've been going.
We've been going for awhile.
Thirty four,
30.
We've been going since two.
Right?
There's probably not a lot of people
working today because today's monday,
the third.
Tomorrow's the fourth people Just say
fuck,
fuck.
Monday.
Then know and get that extRa day.
Independence day.
Tomorrow's the day where people are
going to do some stupid shit.
Was fireworks you doing tomorrow?
Gorilla.
That's great.
Are you doing later tonight?
Tonight we're going to grill some access
dear.
So fresh from Hawaii.
Oh my god.
How did you get you just ship it with
you on the plane.
Is it sort of special?
You just freeze it,
freeze it before you take them back and
put in the cooler.
wow.
Yeah.
Just do you have your permanent for a
certain number of deer that you can.
Not in lanai.
In lanai,
they don't have any predators,
so you could really.
I only shot one of them.
They're really hard to get with a bow
and arrow and it's hard to get close to
them.
They're super.
Well they.
They evolved with tigers.
Will these.
They're so fast.
I this happened more than once.
I shot at one and it ran away from the
arrow.
The arrow is going 200 and switch arrows
because I heavier arrows that go 245
feet a second and in the mid hunt we had
to switch to these other errors that go
275 feet a second.
I had a gain an extra 30 feet a second
because the deer would even then they
still duct it.
They would look at the arrow coming
their way and get the fuck out of dodge
bitch.
Are you kidding me?
I mean,
you're fascinated fast the.
Because they literally evolved running
away from tigers.
Crazy man.
That there's any chance that it's going
off anytime soon.
There's no one around.
We don't have.
We've got issues folks.
Oh,
we can play with the soundtrack.
We don't have to play.
We could do.
We could.
We could definitely just keep doing it.
Does it bother you that this thing has
gone kind of faded into the background?
Weird drinks at this point?
I feel warm.
Smell,
smoke.
When we know it sounded russian.
It was a little swampy shapes.
We want to play some swamps.
I was at this point in time for pool in
New York that had a tiger pell,
famous tiger,
real one real one from the New York.
It's called the explOrer's club places
crazy.
Some snm shit.
Ben can be an s and m,
like a safari type deal.
Like one of those clubs.
It was like maybe late 18,
hundreds of teddy roosevelt started this
place with a bunch of bros and they have
all this taxidermy in this room.
One of them is this pelt of a tiger
tigress that killed 48 people in India.
You had this,
it kind of like,
it was a phenomenon.
He got a taste for blood and started
huntIng men.
People.
I don't know if it was just just men,
but um,
they had this thing on the wall which
was insane.
You know,
that's a real issue in um,
in India,
in India there's a one part of this
river that's very brackish and the
tigers drink the salt water and because
of the typhoons,
a lot of times they wind up having a
bunch of people wash up in the river and
the tigers won a beating people.
So they developed a pension,
a.
Yeah,
they did.
They have a taste for,
for humans to the point where in there,
this one section of India,
over the past 200 years,
tigers have killed over 300,000
people.
People still going there.
It was a bit from one of my specials.
It was a bit from.
I'm talking monkeys in space.
It's weird.
it really is true why they lived there.
The first 100,000,
you're like,
we should leave.
There's nothing really they could do
about it.
It's like they've evolved in that way.
It'S not just like one main,
you know,
predatory tiger,
that's all.
No,
no,
no.
This many,
many,
many tires over hundreds of years the
tigers had gotten used to eating.
People like tiger.
Tiger's are particularly ruthless,
funny story.
When you're like,
I'm afraid of like sharks don't eat
people,
they don't like the way we taste.
How the fuck do you know?
Yeah,
exactly.
They just don't.
They don't.
They can be like,
actually,
I took a bite and that was fucking
delicious.
It's like if you expected you were going
to get cottage cheese,
but instead you got a cantaloupe,
you'd kind of freak out.
You might really get into cantaloupes
after awhile.
I fucking love divers divers.
Delicious to eat them in the wetsuit.
Dude.
I don't give a fuck,
you know?
Well,
you know,
that's not a seal,
right?
yeah,
it's a diver.
It's like you.
Fuck.
Yeah.
This one section of this river in India.
I did this whole bit about it in my,
uh,
2009 comedy special because it was a
real story about a boat of people.
There was five guys in this boat and
three of them were killed by tigers.
So the tiger swam out to the boat,
jumped in,
killed a guy and dragged him into the
water,
swam to the shore,
dropped his body off,
jumped back in the water,
swim out to the boat again,
got the next guy swam for shore.
He just killed a tiger.
Hoarders spree.
That's fucked up.
God.
Damn three guys.
This is real.
Did he make friends with him?
Like real?
Totally real.
I wouldn't lie to you about something so
important.
That's crazy.
Just stop and think about what that must
have been like in the last two guns.
My apartment in silver lake.
God,
the terror.
That's what we need.
Tigers roaming the streets of silver
alert.
We'd let you understand coyotes.
I parked.
They do stay.
You guys are close to griffith park.
I should have brought the pamphlet in
it.
Yeah.
That means that the crooks have found
the bolts and cutting along feels weird
now or soon alone.
So awkward.
There was a guy that I had on,
there was a wildlife biologist.
It was telling me about the cougar that
lives in griffith park and it just.
Just jack's dear.
That's all he does.
And the occasional dog,
they end,
they've monitored this cat,
big cat.
This is a cat.
They have a photo of him with the
hollywood sign that by the way,
we have common.
We have a print of that.
The the new studio has a collar on,
but it's a wild cougar and they have to
capture it every couple of years because
it's color runs out a gps so the battery
dies and the color.
So they have to find this fucker and
then they have to dart them is right
there.
See it has this collar and look in the
background with the hollywood sign.
That's not planned.
That was just a camera trap.
Photograph a random pick that collar.
He was looking for arms like franco
columbo mean.
That's insane.
Forums are fucking shit.
The hollywood sign is actually 10 feet
but lot.
He looks like the rock.
He's built like the rock.
No,
he's building a power lifter.
Almost like his front arm.
Like the phone guy in the middle to the
left with that fucking look on his face.
That same one that sam,
they took a picture of them was edible.
Yeah,
he eats a lot of edibles,
you know what I think is just donors.
I think if you eat stoners,
you get high.
Oh my worst nightmare.
They have to capture this cat every two
years.
Is cat's been captured like four times.
Pretty cute too though.
I think he had manged their right.
Is that what they captured him?
That he had some sort of a dIsease?
they had to work with them on,
but it's so um,
I think his name is [inaudible] right?
Is that his name?
That's what they call them.
Like I noted he was severely infected
with mange.
Yeah,
blow.
Sorry dude.
That sucks.
Intense Life.
And it's a male and he's out there
running free.
That's what's really interesting.
They just let him do what he does.
He's running the shell.
He's king shit.
He's defInitely king shit.
If you're a jogger,
he's like,
simba,
you just don't want to catch them before
you.
If he has a limp and he can't take out
dear anymore,
that's when you're fucked.
You got to be.
And he said,
these are the things that are proper
running.
When we were in like a yellow stone in
and we were driving through,
want to get out of the car,
there's no stone is a pretty
fascinating.
It's beautiful.
I mean,
we went and saw geysers and all the
beautiful stuff,
but like a week later there was some
hiker that just got killed by a grizzly.
And it was like,
there was footage of it.
It was,
there was,
uh,
there was uh,
a,
uh,
not a sheriff that ranger ranger mobio
wouldn't be a major vehicle went by and
the man,
like literally like seconds after the
ranger drove by,
this just huge grizzly goes across the
path.
And there was a hiker who had his
headphones on,
just got here.
But the kid,
11 year old kid that saved a fishing
party yesterday,
no charging grizzly bear at a fishing
party.
And this 11 year old kid down in Alaska.
What gun did down's.
Not a grizzly.
Technically it's a brown bear,
but they're really the same beer with
the grizzly is as a coastal brown bear.
And what a coastal bears called as a
brown bear.
Eleven year old kid charging grizzly
with one well-placed shot.
Where is he exactly?
Tell you for it.
That's the right designation.
Young Harry Potter.
That's what that hat says.
Where's it?
Say it was who?
Not.
Alaska.
Go to go to the map and find out where
the fuck.
Who knows?
11 hoonah.
Alaska.
The kid lives in hoonah,
That's amazing.
Equally,
as sad as it is like way up yonder.
You don't want to see the people die
from the bear,
but then you feel bad for the bear.
That's a.
That's actually a brown bear.
They're calling it a grizzly,
but it's on the coast.
I think I might be wrong.
Diana lived in juneau.
Look,
I'll fucking been.
Alaska is still go back.
He's coming back.
It is.
Do.
I do.
I've been there a bunch.
I've been there a few times for fishing.
I did a show there once and fish.
Salmon.
What?
They're fun fish.
Sure.
I love to fish.
Do it.
So does ben.
Let's start.
Let's do a family vacation planet
tonight at our cookout.
That sounds great.
Just an hour from but I'm.
Alaska is is.
You know what's really crazy?
The thing that I didn't anticipate how
fucking aggressive that mosquitoes are
here because they only live for like a
week.
Oh jesus.
So When they were exaggerating with a
week with the staff,
got to wear the stuff.
Another move is thermacell,
if you want a thermacell is press a
button.
It's an ingenious device that my
friends,
the rivets up in alberta told me about
friends called the rivets rivets,
jon,
jen,
jonathan rivett,
hunting guides in alberta.
But you press this button and it lights
this little tiny element inside of it
and it heats up that blue pack.
Go back to that thing,
that blue pad.
You change those out.
After awhile they become white in that
blue pad.
Puts out this fine mist.
No,
it burns.
It burns off a fine mist that you can't
detect,
but fucking mosquitoes don't want no
part of it.
Amazing.
Yeah,
and it makes your dick rowe.
I just made that up,
but I don't know what to say,
but what does that thermacell.
Are those heated?
Is that heated or is that reallY in
walmart.com?
That goes in your shoe.
This is a thermos sell foot pad that
somehow or another rep keeps mosquitoes.
Maybe not.
Maybe it was.
He didn't have any color.
Other colors except for,
I don't know,
good questions.
Fashion conscious.
When it comes to mosquito protection
with looking into when we lived in
nashville,
I would have To wear off for sensitive
skin during the day because I would get
bit by mosquitoes all day and people
would always tell me that I smelled
amazing.
Oh,
it's off.
So I just.
I write all of my tests with magic
markers.
Good pickup.
What smells better than a fresh magic
word when you pop the top that I don't
even know why you like it,
but you love that.
Smell it.
Again.
I don't even know what to say.
Is it true thermacell makes myself and
just make it dark red myself and stop
it.
Thermacell makes some lawn.
I'm like those little things that you
stick in the ground,
like a little lawn lantern,
but they keep mosquitoes away.
It's the same terms.
So commercial,
because we have a pretty easy in
California with the mosquitoes are easy
with everything,
fucking everything except for
earthquakes.
We get an easy.
We don't have whether he killed the
spider in my bedroom in the middle of
the night last week,
my curtain window.
Imagine if you were living in hoonah,
Alaska grizzly bear,
you caught them out.
The window was right after his app.
Like if you were like screaming from the
spider and you broke the curtain and you
looked out the window as the bear was in
full charge it.
We'll put it all in perspective.
Witness.
Sure.
What jim like,
goddammit.
Really didn't have a big deal.
That's pretty good.
Eleven year old hunter.
It seems like you've kind of evaluated
east.
He's fucking own in that shit.
Bitches are on planes.
Go out and visit this kid.
There's older women that tend towards
pedophilia that are right now grooming.
They just didn't want to wait a few
years.
That's what they do.
No,
they don't want to go to jail.
So the older girls,
they just become your friend and mentor
you for a few years and then when you
hit 18 they just just sucking.
That's what they tell you.
That's just telling you.
That's what I hear because a lot of
women are realizing wrongly.
So they get arrested for having sex with
these young boys.
I think it's just let it go.
But once these women do realize that
there's real consequences to it,
what they do is just to friend them.
They become friends with these kids that
long.
They hang it.
It's not dark.
It's only darkness.
Girl.
Trust us.
Right then.
Sure.
Oh your way around a woman's heart.
You have an issue that she's 25.
She really likes you.
She teaches you art and crafts and,
and how skilled ceramicist she's really,
she's really good at making ashtrays and
so I get it.
I'm in.
And on that note,
where do we go from here?
Oh geez.
So many options under the desk into a
fetal position that mary kay letourneau
the girl that,
uh,
she's still With that boy and they had a
fake divorce.
They had to get a divorce because he's
going into the wheat business.
Really?
They only got divorced so that she
wouldn't be like legally,
uh,
it wouldn't be like a legal issue with
him selling weed with him and her.
He was protecting her so they got a
divorce,
but they're still together.
unhappy.
Apparently story like that coming out
like every week right now.
But like a young teacher,
a substitute teacher,
24 accused of sex in two counties with
her 17 year old student.
Okay.
It's only seven years difference folks.
You got to let that go.
My parents have a huge age gap between
them.
Cute.
Yeah.
How many years had you want to get
close?
50.
How old is ben's dad?
Seventy,
78.
Not playing by the rules.
First of all,
I want you to go.
You have to.
Okay.
Look,
I've been playing this game my whole
life.
so three things.
I can tell you.
Three things.
One,
okay.
I'm 31 years old.
I'm about to turn 32.
Second thing is my dad is crazy,
fucking old.
Crazy.
And the third thing is one person in my
entire life has ever guessed old enough.
I mean you can go crazy.
Huge booty.
Okay already so hard to get a free pass.
They're the oldest guy ever.
Okay.
I think your dad is 95 years old.
You're actually spot on really turning
96 in november.
That disturbs me.
I hate want to just take a shot in the
dark.
But obviously you gave me a lot of
parameters to work in.
Generally crazy old.
If it was your first guest,
people on the parameters never guessed
that.
Never.
I love that.
Joe.
Just guests.
Your dad's proper age and he'll be 96 in
november.
Yeah.
Dude,
what are you.
What the fuck is going on?
Who may just as I was just a lucky guess
if I guessed when you didn't tell me he
was crazy.
Old data would be impressive.
Feel like you give people,
but you hear what I'm saying?
Nobody has ever done it.
Yeah.
But that doesn't matter.
But you just said like,
I got lucky.
Listen,
but if you,
if you like,
this is why like psychics or problem.
they start leading you and then they
give you a bunch of information,
you get a bunch of information first.
Then they take a guest,
like if I told you that I was a psychic
and then we went through this whole
thing.
I sense your dad is.
He's getting,
he's getting on,
but maybe not.
Maybe he is.
I mean maybe he's doing well.
You're right.
Your dad is.
My dad's really older.
He,
he's,
I feel like he's older.
Am I onto something you'd be like,
yes,
yes.
I feel like I feel like it's a big
issue.
I feel like he's older than you would
admit it.
It's definitely been a thing,
so I feel like he's,
I wanT to say is 95.
Oh my god.
That seems like psychic.
That's what psychics do.
ThoSe fucks pitches.
Like I had a friend of mine and he went
to a psyche.
It's like dude's got a knew all aBout my
grandmother.
I'm like,
don't you know about grandma?
You know about your grandma.
RIght?
So this guy knew some shit that you
already know.
Tell this guy to tell you some shit that
you don't know.
You want someone to tell you thIngs you
already know that is fucking ridiculous.
You're going to set her off because
she's going,
no,
not a bad way,
but.
And I've only,
I've never experienced it first hand.
I've never had a psychic or someone with
that kind of energy.
Tell me something that I was like,
wait,
what the fuck did you just like?
What?
There's people like you in my life who I
trust,
who have had experiences that are
unexplainable psychics tell me a family
secrets that I've bent over backwards to
try to understand how they could
possibly know what they knew and I'm
always skeptical.
That definitely had people that told me
things that there's fucking no way they
could know.
Here's the question though.
Did you give them any answers to other
questions before that?
No.
None.
So they just told you right away your
uncle's gay and he has a boy that he
lives with.
He pretends to son,
but it's really those.
Joe,
what the fuck?
Are you serious?
Right?
without hesiTation,
yes,
without that.
But something that ridiculous,
outrageous that they could only guess
and you didn't give him any answers to
any leading questions before that I
thought I heard on your podcast.
Maybe not,
but there is a documented history of the
military experimenting with.
So I mean if severe amending,
but for years and years and years,
money if there's no actual question,
no,
that's not necessarily true because they
wanted to find out if there was an
answer and the only way you find out is
if you have,
you have to run some tests and they had
a thing called remote viewing.
And uh,
we actually had some real remote viewing
experts on that tv show that I did for
awhile called the joe rogan questions.
Everything.
We sat down with them and I had all
these,
these remote viewing guys low
at the end of the dose.
It seems a lot like psychics.
It's like there's no,
like they,
they claim to have seen some things and
pointed out some things that helped some
operations and this and that.
But it's all top secret.
Whether or not it's true,
you're never gonna know.
You're never goIng to know whether
they're bullshitting you or something
really did go down,
but I've never seen anybody do it.
We had two guys try to do it.
There were supposedly extra sentence
they couldn't do shit
and I think there's a lot of people that
aren't authentic.
But that's true.
There's a lot of money in shenanigans.
There's a lot of money in palm reading
that people that aren't going to charge
you the money are probably the people
that are actually doing something that
is meeting
for maybe.
Or It might be like a Stephen King book
were you driving down the street and see
that neon light and it says fortune
teller and you'd go in and it's some
lady who sees through your soul and she
does and she really does know things and
it's just like this is how she gets by
with this magic gift.
You just pay 20 bucks a pop and she just
tells you crazy shit and you do what you
do with that.
But she knows and no one ever believes.
She knows.
Cause it doesn't make any sense as
fucking lady on ventura and victory like
fuck the more job.
How does she know?
She know all this,
but she does.
Ventura doesn't intersect with the
victory.
Oh wow.
There's the catch.
So when you're in the police office
telling them,
no,
I'm telling you the police was there.
It was real.
She was a real person.
I remembered the wilson's had been
living on ventura and victory for 37
years and they've never moved.
You get back to the house.
It's the house
where.
Where did,
where did the.
Where did fortune teller or you make it
fun.
But I know I want to believe you right?
Because we're going to talk about this
at the barbecue.
My buddy.
So you really believe you believe in
psychics.
I've,
I've had too many things that I can't
explain that I am always going to
question.
But I have you.
Has anybody ever told you something was
going to happen then it happened?
I don't like that shit and I don't.
I don't subscribe to that.
So if you shut your mouth,
I don't subscribe to that because I
don't want someone to tell me my future.
I don't,
I don't.
I think that's unfair and I think that's
disrespectful.
I Think that weird word to use the
experiences I've had with these people
were with people that have died that uh,
I,
I've communicated with whether through
dreams or psychedelics and I had
questions but I didn't ask them and I
waited to see if they would tell me.
And it's just kind of that sort of
setup.
Here's the thIng,
it might be real and it might be that
real.
What real is,
is so ridiculous that it's almost like
you can't bottle it,
you can't measure it,
you can't put it on the scale and it
only exists in these brief moments and
it comes and it goes.
You'll never be able to prove it and it
just comes and it goes and it makes you
think like,
god,
I think I really believe that really,
really did happen and no one really
knows and everybody just goes about
their.
But it really
did.
he really did tap in.
He really did talk to someone who's not
there anymore.
I think whether you did or didn't,
um,
is,
is up to your acceptance of the
experience and whether it's your ego or
something you can't explain and if it
brings you comfort,
that's great for sure.
if it brings you comfort,
right?
I mean that's the same argument for
religion.
YOu know,
when people say the religions bullshit,
you go mom,
but it's bullshit that makes people
happy.
If it makes people happy then it's not
bullshit.
It's bullshit that makes people happy
and also controls people and does really
terrible things.
So it's also have to do all those
things.
But really,
I mean there's a lot of,
it's very multifaceted subject sugar,
but sugar sugar kills a lot of people,
but it also tastes delicious.
If you could just mention it,
like gets people.
But you know what's funny,
like I found out recently that a
scientology,
oh religion is I'm the one of the main
backers for a narcotics anonymous.
They are look it up,
I believe.
Tell me I'm wrong and going wrong.
Well they definitely don't like
psychiatric medicine and,
and so that's a really interesting
window into manipulation and tRying to
get people to subscribe to something and
here's the thing,
there's a lot of fucking shit out there
and I,
I don't,
I don't know what's right,
I can just speak to my own experiences
and things that I absolutely questioned
with,
with so much thought and,
and continue to do so from things that
have happened years ago and I just,
I,
I can't deny how I felt and what I've
experienced and I want to keep living
and understanding whatever it is,
uh,
if,
you know,
there's a reason why we're here or there
isn't and we're just here,
but I,
I,
I'm,
I'm not religious.
I feel a really.
I feel inTerested in religion and some
of the things I've experienced over the
years being raised catholic and you're
kind of talking about a religious
experience.
Sure,
sure.
I mean,
what do you think that everyone's going
to think of specific?
It had this argument.
It doesn't need is did we are,
we are.
Because iT's not really a religion to
me,
it's not like some organized religion.
I'm the spiritual energetic exchange of
information because I guess I equate
religion and this is where we can all
talk about this and like I am,
so I don't know if I'm right,
I'm not like preaching,
but no one knows if you're wrong either,
but,
but religion to me is like the
catholicism.
I was raised on that and that requires
um,
guilt and wrongfulness and sin and money
because you go to church and you put
your money in the basket every sunday.
And I,
I don't,
I've,
I've seen enough and I know enough about
pedophilia within the catholic church
that's undeniable.
You can't fucking deny any.
I'm talking about organization and
that's how I equate religion.
Sure.
But I think the different people,
not the exact same that narcan and on.
Okay.
Synonymous is so narcan is what the
scientology be people.
It's an organization that promises
promotes rather than theories of
scientology.
Founder l ron hubbard regarding
substance abuse.
Same thing as narcotics or similar
groups.
I appreciate that in his,
you know,
all of l ron hubbard stuff,
a lot of it came from other psychology
textures and lectures rather than texts
and books and stuff.
If you read the rudimentary levels of of
l ron hubbard's teachings,
they're like amazing and then they start
getting weirder and weirder and you're
like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
It's really interesting and I think
that's even.
He didn't believe in psychics.
I know.
What are you saying?
I don't really believe in psychics
either.
I just believe in my experiences.
I think that there's a.
There's a difference.
I think there's a lot of.
I think you should question everything
and then try to understand yourself the
best that you can.
I think that unique moments can be
unique.
I think there's this things have
happened When you think about someone on
the phone rings and they can tell you
all day long.
That's a coincidence,
man.
How often do you think about them and
the phone doesn't ring.
The might be,
you might be right,
but there are some pretty unique moments
that I'm not exactly convinced our
measurable.
I don't know if they're measurable.
Right.
I think those unique moments where you
think about someone,
they text you.
I don't.
I don't necessarily think that there's
been adequate studies doing done on that
and I think there's a lot of people that
have these contrarion ideologies that
they really love to dismiss things like
this and they really love to dismiss the
potential connections that people have
between each other,
but we know we have connections when
we're near each other.
We know that like some people can just
look at you and you look at them and
let's get the fuck out of here.
We have like people have weird
connections with the other.
You also know when someone's upset at
you and they're not being honest about
it.
You know,
like there's weird.
We have weird sort of ways of feeling
each other out that don't necessarily
fit on a scale but not quantifiable,
but they're,
they're,
they're.
You can't measure them,
but you feel them.
That's funny.
I was reading this article about that
kind of ties into music too,
that just talking about,
you know,
the,
so you're talking about our ability to
read each other's facial expressions,
emotional expressions,
and that's a successful trade,
you know,
that's something that's part of the
development stuff,
right?
Um,
and basically this,
I'm just getting into it,
but this article is just talking about
how those,
it's just a lot of scientists trying to
understand are people like why the fuck
is music important?
Like this doesn't know,
why is this such an obsession?
Human obsession just is a drug to that.
I mean it certainly is like even like
the other day I was watching rocky four,
rocky ford came on just out of nowhere
else flipping to and songs that I don't
even think are good anymore,
you know,
but I recognize the drug like effect
that like one of those rocky songs will
survive a rocky songs.
But it's a combination of the movie and
the music.
Yes.
It's not just the music,
there's the visual,
but sometimes not.
Sometimes just the music.
You know,
like when I run,
when I run and if I listen to music,
I can go longer for sure.
Was that what the fuck's goIng on there?
How come you're not as tired when you're
listening to an emotional response?
You're inspired.
You're inspired by something that was,
that was taught to you at a,
at a different time than the rhythm of
the music was,
was ingrained in you.
At some point I can listen to motley
crue,
kickstart my heart and I can get up any
fucking hell.
I would imagine if you take an
indigenous tribe in,
played like rock music,
they'd be like,
what the fuck?
They had no idea what it was,
but maybe they wouldn't because there's,
there's rhythm and there's a lot of um,
there's a lot of musical,
a tribal contributions to that area of
your life as a dancer.
Exactly.
We're not off the rails.
Right?
We're good.
We're so good at.
That's what you're saying.
I feel like this is our best one yet.
Maybe we've said that before.
I don't know.
I haven't done one in awhile.
It was over two years.
Two years.
Oh well shit,
shit.
Damn,
you guys are still the only band I've
ever worked with.
Come on.
Never worked with a band before.
Never did shows.
We did a couple shows.
Those are fun.
Such a blast.
They were so much fun.
Oh my gosh.
We had a new year's together.
You are so great.
You.
You were like,
people were trying to count down and you
weren't done with your bit and you were
like,
fuck you.
I'm not done.
And then you said,
okay,
now we can celebrate the new year.
It was amazing.
It was so great.
Was in the middle of a bit.
People are booked.
Darn.
I missed it by 10 seconds folks.
Hang in there.
Well we did the end of the world pod or
twice whether to new year's December
21st,
2012 was the big one.
That was the first one we did.
We did the end of the world one.
Which stan hope and joy and new year's
though.
It wasn't new years.
December 20.
First.
It was the end of the calendar.
We planned that one out in advance.
Yeah,
we knew we were going to do stand up and
I talked about doing that like because
he got tired of me talking about the
mayan calendar.
Let's fucking promise we're going to do
a show December 21st week.
Let's do it.
Let's get deals on board and you know I
met you guys went to clinton because I'm
a fucking crazy end of the world from
December 24th
and then the life went on for five more
years.
Like everything was going.
Hey,
thanks for bringing us on.
that was a lot of fun.
it was fun for us too.
It's fun.
How did you get.
So how did you get the Alex Jones one to
be nine slash 11.
Nine slash 11.
I had to plan it out.
Do I had to fit some podcast in?
I had to do like extra ones the week
before just so I could get to number
nine slash 11 with alex.
Right,
wasn't it?
That sounds like a long seat of had him
on earlier and I would've definitely had
them on again for nine slash 11.
But having them on the first time for
nine slash 11,
and to this day,
that's our biggest podcast by far,
by maybe $5 million downloads.
Fuck yeah.
But here's the conspiracy,
right?
Is that right?
Am I saying correctly?
What is the actual number?
16 now?
I didn't check in the last two to three
days,
but okay,
so $16,000,000.
Here's what's crazy.
It never charted on itunes.
The itunes charts magically went down
while the Alex Jones podcast was in
acute and they stayed down for over a
week conspiracy theory and then when it
came back up,
podcasts that got way less downloads
than alex's,
we're re were rated much higher than
his.
And theY had happened before and after
his was the only podcast that was left
out of the ratings loop,
like for sure it would have been the
number one podcast in the country.
It was the number one podcast we did by
a mile and I've had the number one
podcast before.
so the number one podcast episode that
was more than 5 million downloads more
than any other podcasts I had before.
Crazy.
So it's should for sure,
probably would have been number one if
it wasn't a lot of downloads,
unless they had like one of those serial
episodes or something that came out that
week.
So there you go.
And that's it.
It's very likely that someone's trying
to hold Alex Jones back.
Stokes his fucking.
They don't understand this,
the streisand effect.
And stoke the fire of Alex Jones.
Even megan kelly's.
Fuck.
Now her show's going down the toilet.
What happened in the aftermath?
She.
Here's the.
Here's the problem.
Megan kelly was a fox news person.
She left fox news to go to nbc.
Nbc is thought of as cnbc,
which is thought of as fake news by
these right wing trump.
Trump bands.
What would you call them?
Trump trumpers.
So as soon as she goes over there,
they're not going to listen to her.
And then to the liberals,
she's fox news so they're not interested
in either.
and then she does this podcast with Alex
Jones or this interview rather with Alex
Jones and the interview with Alex Jones.
She says,
I'm not going to paint you out as a
monster.
I'm going to give you a fee,
like she's saying all these things.
She's going to throw softballs this way.
I want people to get to know you,
and he releases all that and he's like,
hey,
this is that person,
and then the ratings just keep you
gotta.
If you want to be an ice princess,
you gotta gotta go fox news full life.
You want.
You want to sell guns,
you want to be a second amendment
proponent.
Which fucking cold,
blue steel eyes and smooth,
shiny legs and
nice shoes and tiny skirts.
You got to be on fox news.
How do you get smith's?
Got to shAve them down constantly.
All day long.
Yeah.
You have oil them up to.
Yeah,
you have illegal immigrants.
It's just kind of a natural thing for
me.
Oh,
really?
You're hairless in the legs and somebody
has got to be like that,
right?
I got to be somebody out there with no
leg hair.
I'm sure it happens.
It's called purity.
Sure.
What it's called.
Sure has been brought it up one day.
We're all going to have no hair and
they're gonna.
Look back at pictures of us going to go,
what the fuck were they doing?
What is that?
The human race,
facial hair and shit.
Everyone to know why brows and lashes.
I really think that's the future.
I think the future is those aliens for
close encounters.
I think the reason why we have those
archetypal images in our head that says
we know that's what we're going to talk
to paul hellyer or looked at his stuff.
He's like the canadian alien,
david.
They're all the same,
but he was.
He was part of the government.
The government will have him for sure.
He's telling the truth.
He specifically talks about the
different types of aliens.
Oh,
well that makes them even more legit for
sure.
With no evidence.
He definitely would tell us all about
these.
All different brands you might want to
have them on.
I have,
unfortunately.
I'm not saying there's no events.
I don't know him,
but I know the whole alien alien.
You don't want people to know.
I think there's a business.
Values are who you are.
Problem is there's a business and
telling people the candidates,
aliens would give us some more tech if
we'd stop wars.
All right,
let's play this.
I want to hear this.
What's that?
Oh,
it's not,
but it's on our team,
but why is he the one?
He was on our t this.
Why don't you talk to her,
but it says on our t proof of aliens.
Presidents overwhelmed.
That's just a picture of it.
That's just a screenshot was on.
right?
So he's got to be.
It's got to be a video of it.
No,
there's many videos of paul hellyer.
Do you buy it when you listen to them
talk?
It makes me question to hear.
I'm interested.
I'd like to hear his voice to see if my
crazy radar goes off.
Just give me a little on what you feel.
You got two different shit.
Plan.
Jamie's a tabber.
Well,
because I know that they are.
As a matter of fact,
they've been visiting our planet for
thousands of years and one of the cases
that would interest you most if they're
getting two or three minutes to answer
is during the cold war.
Nineteen 61 there were about 50 ufo
information flying south from Russia to
the across europe and the supreme allied
commander was very concerned,
um,
and about ready to press the panic
button when they turned around and went
back over the north pole.
So they decided to do an investigation
and the investigators for three years
and they decided that with absolute
certainty that for species for different
species,
at least I've been visiting this planet
for thousands of years.
So that's a,
we have a long history of ufo is.
And of course there's been a lot more
activity on the last few decades since
we invented the atomic bomb and they're
very concerned about,
uh,
about that and the fact that,
we might use it again and because the
whole cosmos is a unity and it affects
not just us,
but other people in the cosmos,
there are very much afraid that we might
be stupid enough to start using atomic
weapons again.
And this would be very bad for us and
for them as well.
So no serious scientists has ever
publicly confirmed evidence of an
encounter with extraterrestrials.
Why would scientists not confirm the
facts if they exist?
I'm afraid they must go out of their way
to not to find out because if they
didn't,
you know,
even 10 percent of the amount of
research I've done in the last eight
years,
they would be as convinced as I am.
I mean,
they could do it even faster,
um,
by taking them a little longer when they
didn't have a military background.
But,
uh,
there are so many wonderful books that
tell these stories and uh,
and they've been authenticated.
The sightings have been authenticated by
more than one witness and also by.
Right?
Okay.
This is the same horseshit debit
authenticated by witnesses.
There's,
that doesn't mean anything.
There's no real video.
There's no real photographs.
Nothing looks good.
A lot of people were talking about it.
But when you think about how many human
beings there are,
there's 320 million plus in America.
How many of them are crazy?
At least one percent.
That's 3 million,
200,000
crazy people.
How many of them are really believe what
they're saying?
At least half.
So you got 100.
You got a lot of fucking crazy people.
Well this is one video,
so I've watched a couple of his and it's
just,
it's interesting to think about in terms
of like we're here.
It's interesting to think about,
but as soon as someone starts talking
like that,
he says they've been authenticated.
There was more than one witness.
That means nothing.
People are full of shit.
you just.
I saw something doesn't mean anything
you might've you might not have,
but if he's 100 percent all in and he
hasn't had a ufo experience himself that
he's talking about,
then he seems gullible.
I talked to a lot of those people.
I talked to those people that had been.
I talked to people that have had
implants pulled out of their body.
I talked to people that were experts.
Oh,
it's gone.
What does it say?
You've seen one?
Yeah,
well it's something that gives me a
light.
Mine haven't seen one,
but I'm curious to know.
But what he just said there did not
impress me because he said that multiple
people had seen it like more than one
person had confirmed it.
That doesn't mean like
you could have five guys that ally.
That doesn't mean they might tell the
truth.
I don't think so.
italians call my people.
Do the ooh folks.
Yeah,
I've never heard that.
Is it two?
Oh,
two in a row do Harry Potter was a fail,
but I came back around.
It wasn't 100 percent.
It's not to dismiss,
dismiss the possibility of ufo.
It's just that you gotta really be
careful with how people talk about
stuff.
You got to be,
you know,
if someone starts talking that they know
something and that's.
That's one video.
I've Watched a few of his videos and
they were really interesting.
He was,
he was speaking with for canadian
congress talking about this and I,
I've watched a lot of it in its entirety
and it's just worth thinking about.
That's all.
I don't know what the truth is.
I think.
yeah,
sure,
please.
Yeah,
always.
Just the fact that he has a lot of
videos out there,
it makes me wonder because that means
that he's making a living doing this or
this is this,
this is a gig.
This is a thing he does your speaking
before the canadian congress chorus,
if he does a bunch of these other
interviews as well that allows them to
speak in front of.
That's his thing.
His thing is I'm the guy who knows
everything about ufo.
Right,
but if you were talking to scientists,
they would say,
show us the residence.
Right.
There's nothing.
That's the thing about these guys.
They all have stories and no one has any
evidence.
I mean feel evidence,
but it feels good to think that they're
out there.
Right.
I want to know.
I want to know stuff.
I mean like look at all the shit that we
have and we're here and all the things
that we have,
all the resources that we use and we're
one planet in the universe full of other
plants.
That's all it is.
Way up there.
I'm not afraid to say that.
I'm.
I'm curious.
I think people generally,
it feels like a normal thing to be like,
yeah,
they're fucking out there,
but what I think is hard to accept this
evidence.
What's hard to accept is that they're
communicating with us and only certain
people like paul hellyer,
no,
maybe he does know and maybe he has seen
something,
but maybe he's full of shit.
The problem is if you haven't seen it
and I haven't,
or at least I don't think I have and
you're,
you're talking about these things,
how much,
how much time you spend thinking and
talking about them.
Like it gets to become almost like a
pathology,
like why are you so invested in
something that you don't even know his
real,
but it becomes a thing that people were
into,
like they're into baseball scores or the
random bowling.
They get into ufo,
they get into it and then they start.
I mean this dude's obviously making a
career out of it.
He's out there traveling.
That's something to,
to investigate upon this conversation,
but it makes me think for years,
like I've seen some videos and I'm just
like,
wow,
okay.
It makes me think that's all.
Maybe I will always be curious about
that.
About aliens and psychics and all the
shit.
It's so controversial way where it's
like yes or no,
I just don't know,
but I want to know.
I'd love to keep learning I to,
but I think that with guys like this,
when you're talking about a subject
that's this mercurial,
is this such a difficult subject?
I think it's very impOrtant to only talk
about the actual facts,
like what we know or what we Don't know.
If he wants to talk about his own
personal experience,
that's one thing,
but when you start talking about stories
that you heard like people are full of
shit from the beginning of time when
telling stupid stories about werewolves
and vampires and of damages done to.
It's like it's all derivative passed
down like,
oh,
I heard this from this and this and
this,
but you weren't there so you don't know.
It's like I'm reading this book about
our brains and how our recollection of a
memory of memories and like eye
witnesses are usually inaccurate,
inaccurate because you don't really
remember like you think you did in your
brain lies to you and tells you that you
saw something a certain way and,
and even that like,
I dunno,
it's very important for people are
absolutely a lot of people out there
that think their memories are super
accurate and this ties into being wrong.
This ties into being like I didn't see
it the way that I think I did and I
might've made a mistake and I'm sorry.
You know,
that's okay.
That's important too because I think a
lot of times when you have some big
statement about something that you
believe in or,
or like if you want to get down to
having some sort of a trial of this or
that and you say,
I remember it just like this.
It's dramatic and emotional sell it.
It's element like you're running for
congress,
it's,
it's $40,000
day.
Frightening really is.
It is people that are trying to convince
people.
I mean that's one of the reasons why
being a president so crazy because
you're basically like trying to trick
people into liking.
You try to be charismatic and that's
what sells the most.
I made a mistake.
Do they ever say,
I'm sorry I messed up.
I'm sure.
So he wants to publicly.
I don't know.
I think there's those moments.
I think it's probably be really
interesting.
I was going to happen to him.
Is going to have to happen some day.
So seeing your child.
I don'T know which one that is.
Partially.
I think you sound great.
You sound great.
I know you guys sound great.
What?
Come on and sing a song.
Do you want to do that?
When I read this up,
we'd been doing for three hours and 20
minutes and then we started a little
late so yeah,
but it's 5:20
to 45.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh,
one of the things that a 2:00
we didn't.
We did another podcast afterward.
That's how we broke it in half.
Then what do you want to play?
Whatever.
so we have solo records coming out.
Oh sure.
You guys
practice together with your solo shit?
We did.
Because we support each other.
We sure did.
And do on my record.
Comes out August 11th.
That's my birthday.
Is it really what?
Joe was like an old man.
You want to come to my release on August
10th in la?
You are welcome.
All right.
Shit.
I don't have a release date.
I gotta get my shit together.
A beautiful record.
Shit blowing me,
man.
Music,
Let's pull your song first.
Oh jesus.
You want to do that pressure?
Get deep here.
I couldn't probably.
I'm not ready.
I couldn't possibly do you like.
Oh,
you're not going to play on it.
You just didn't sing.
I can.
Here we go.
Okay.
All right.
You can do the instrumental part which
is called.
It's called everlasting peace.
So shit.
Shit.
Sot nom there go.
Some days I'll wake up in a sweat bodies
with from the tension they beam.
Okay.
With all these cheap thrills from
tangible achievements weighing heavy on
my
show me.
You're the only one who can bring me the
You're the only one who can be.
Amy.
Please,
so I could pass a walk,
lift me up like daytime talk like arena
rock and I
sing it to you soft and sweet
from the questions.
Tom,
you're the only one who can bring the
everlasting,
the show me the last thing.
That'd be a violin solo,
but we don't have the violin render
here.
We'll skip that part.
I say it that.
I don't mean
don't want to come from my knees.
Don't want to lose myself in some days
guys,
but I know.
No.
Show me the only lasting p.
Tom,
your the only one who can bring the ama.
Ama.
Ask me.
Dude,
you guys have such a good sound
together.
That's two people that have been working
together for a long time to know each
other's sound.
I might have messed that up a little bit
for ben and make difference.
How'd you mess it up?
Oh,
you know it's new stuff.
It's like I'm Just going to shut my
mouth and open it up with singing.
okay.
We're gonna do now.
I'm.
This is.
This is my single
off my new record that comes out on your
Birthday.
Oh,
ghost in my bed.
Um,
it wasn't music
video out for it.
Now if anyone wants,
where does someone get that?
Because youtube.
Is that okay?
It's on youtube.
Youtube and uh,
coincidentally eight is kcrws toone of
the day today.
I don't even know how that's possible.
Well,
it's a little loud.
Okay.
I'm going to tune it up like a real
professional turned up with your phone.
No.
Yeah.
Really?
Yes.
Joseph.
They have these things that the
instruments.
What is it on your phone?
Like I'm totally ignorant to this.
What is this microphone frequency?
Right?
What is it called?
Just an app.
It's a guitar tuner.
Just hundreds of them.
Oh wow.
There's a bunch of them here.
What are you singing right now?
Wow.
And it works off of the microphone on
your phone the same way one would work
sonically.
It could be at a better situation.
Should I give it another angle?
No,
that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
You want to do this?
Wait,
should I get my pick or should I go
fingers?
you get your pig pen.
Like a real pig with you constantly
Because I'm playing all fingers.
these shirts.
What's that at?
There might be one.
Oh,
there are.
Fuck.
Are you sure?
I'm just kinda picked bro.
I'm done with them.
Stomping around my drinking
booze.
He makes me thinks it's so funny.
Yeah.
Car and says,
oh lord kids.
The
kcrw song.
That was awesome.
Thanks.
My pleasure.
Here's the shit.
I took my headphones off.
I hope I didn't ruin the beautiful.
Perfect.
Don't say a word here.
Everyone's fine.
Should we do more?
Should we go eat?
It's up to you.
Dude.
Do you guys want to do.
I'll do one more sweep.
Well,
here's the thing.
We're going to be on a tv show.
Did we tell him about that on August
3rd?
We're on a show on tbs called the guest
book and we wrote a bunch of music for
it and we are on every episode of this
half hour comedy.
What we play.
I played the mail lady who delivers the
mail and ben plays the exterminator.
Wait a minute,
you guys here.
You put music in your acting on the
show.
We got paid a sag actors.
What is this show?
You know,
so there was a show called.
My name is earl,
you know,
that's.
Yes.
Okay.
So the guy greg garcia.
Great job.
By the way.
Greg garcia loves you and you should
have him on the show.
He's an amazing guy.
Wonderful.
Also talked about doing something at a
meeting with him a lot.
You should have him on the show.
I can help fucking make that connection.
So convention.
I would love to.
I liked that guy.
Yeah,
he's a great.
So what happened?
So they just,
they needed a band.
I guess they were looking at kind of
like a spur of the moment thing.
Greg is like,
okay,
I'm thinking there's going to be a band
that closes out every episode.
Kind of transitions between the strip
club,
the episodes and a friend of ours.
Oh my gosh.
The show.
Oh my god.
Or jamie presley.
This is crazy.
Damn.
Now I want to watch this show.
I love him so much.
Did you guys work with jamie?
Yeah,
once the.
We got to do a scene in aa with her.
It was really fun.
I did a terrible movie with her weight,
never went anywhere.
Is it called?
I don't remember,
but she was super nice.
Oh,
danny pudi.
he's is this the guestbook premiers
August 3rd and it's on tbs.
It'll look.
He's got all the things I want weirdos
in a log cabin,
boom song that didn't make it on the
show,
but what the fuck happened?
That song punk kid.
Like where's that at?
What's the status of that song honeys?
Fourth record when we're ready to make a
great song.
And that song,
like the riff from that song was on my
denver comedy special rocky mountain
high,
but I love that song.
That song is fucking great.
Like what happened?
It will on our last record was a snafu.
There was some kind of label politics a
little bit like it was a little more
rock and roll and it wasn't as americana
and it just,
it was our choice to keep it off.
Eventually it got turned around and
around and around,
but that is a song that we.
This was a couple years ago,
we came out here to work with a great
dude and kiefer's chancy a cnco,
um,
and we just did a set and there was that
and a couple other songs that we did
that,
that were ours.
We own this music,
but when things are,
we owned it and they didn't want to pay
for it,
they didn't want it,
so we were going to record,
they would have owned it and not have.
So we were like,
fuck,
we put all this effort into this song
and we love this song,
but it was just that thing where like we
had to fight for it and it's a great
song and it's not going anywhere.
It'll,
it'll come,
it'll come out eventually.
Dirty people don't know about that song
though.
Bar ilan myths.
We played it here.
Oh,
that's right.
They played back in the desert.
So both those classes,
it never made it on anything else other
than that youtube videos at all.
Anything else where people can listen to
it?
Well,
we put it out.
People downloaded it.
We used it to raise money for this
vehicle.
So we never put it down on rates on
spotify.
It's only,
you guys own it.
So if we played it,
it wouldn't.
It wouldn't like trip any alarms or
anything.
Right.
You can play it anytime you want with
that shit right now.
Go cook.
You find it?
I can buy the version they played for
sure.
See if I can see of the.
Not the burden they played here.
Let's see if there's another version of
it that you can find like the pure
studio version because it's so good.
That was a cool one.
What's the.
Uh,
I bet he loved that song.
There was like one of my favorite on the
new album came out.
I was like,
where's the song?
Whereas punk kid,
it was a big debate.
Who is a real thing of the fockers
motherfuckers know you.
You just got to keep forging ahead and
figuring out how to maintain your
integrity and also what you've worked
for.
And that was,
we just didn't want to give it up.
We didn't want someone else to be like,
yeah,
we own this.
Well,
I'm glad you didn't,
but I can't imagine how you guys do it
because if that was me and I like,
I found out that my jokes like,
uh,
a bit that I did that I worked really
long and hard on all of a sudden if I
wanted to put it on a special,
someone else who's going to own it
without even paying me for it,
I'd be like,
fuck you,
man.
That's crazy.
This is why I'm making my own furniture
for my apartment.
I'm happy you want to word this
computer.
It's on another computer.
Hold on y'all.
What is it?
Is it on spotify?
Is that what you guys said?
That don't have it anywhere.
That's why my itunes.
You want me to.
Oh,
here it is.
I got it right here.
Can we do.
How do I send it to you?
Jamie?
You can plug it in there.
You've got an ox.
No,
it's one of those stupid ass.
God damn fucking isilon's.
Android phones have an ox.
What can I do?
Okay.
I've seriously considered enjoyed
several times.
Here's a new one.
This new.
Here we go.
I got it,
a google pixel two's coming out and then
also the new galaxy s eight.
It doesn't set on fire.
No,
the new.
The note eight is the one.
The note seven was the one that went on
fire to the galaxy seven.
Never went out all over the airports
too.
It's like,
oh,
just so you know.
Yeah,
so there's the galaxy s eight is dope.
I've thought about that one.
And then the galaxy note eight,
which is coming out soon.
It's pretty killer to there.
They're just as good as iphones now.
It's just getting off the apple tit is
the issue.
You know apple,
the apple tit that connects you to ipod
or itunes,
it makes your life more convenient,
but I'm on the google to too.
I love google.
I use it all the time.
It's a juicy one.
It's at least a d cup.
So much information.
I mean what I mean,
if I had to choose between a company
that I rely on more,
if I could just use a google phone,
but I could still use google.
Right.
Well you got to go with google,
right?
That's giant.
I used that way more than I use
anything.
I was like googling things.
I mean,
who doesn't?
You need to know shit.
I need to.
My shoe size and european size.
Very big.
That's a good one.
If you wanted to order some shoes from
oversees 1400 feet as well.
I do,
yeah.
Sasquatch feet.
Big ass.
Why?
I could probably out foot theaters.
London.
Him?
Yeah.
I've been on this trail.
Run and kick.
Aromatase feet.
Choose those five finger shoes are fun
people.
I've never seen a foot product generates
so much hate.
Were those vibram fivefingers shoes?
TheY don't like the way it looks.
how do you feel about it?
I don't give a fuck.
How do you wear a fanny pack at the
grocery store?
The other lump me in with him.
Make me get rid of my numBers.
Kid.
He had a fanny pack.
Sorry.
But a lot of people were them now
because he knew you were.
She didn't know that you knew.
How do I feel when I wear them as though
you're saying it's hard because I'm
running.
I'm rocky hills and I'm running a lot of
miles,
so like three miles on these
various great porn star name.
Sorry.
Ridiculous tits.
Just jesus.
what the fuck Is this?
Out of her shirt?
That's rocky hills.
But um,
it's tricky.
Like today I ran him in like a under
armour trail shoes,
which I gotta be honest.
I kinda liked Better because you can
just run full on.
they have a lot of great shit.
I'm wondering if there,
there,
uh,
one of the most eco,
a athletic lines.
That's really.
Yeah.
They're also one of the very few big
companies that support huntIng.
They have a whole hunting line and that,
that means that's a choice to endorse
honey.
Honey.
We are willing and ready.
Big fan.
Big fan of under armour.
The gauntlet has been thrown down for
rock and roll.
Are you ready to expand stage where?
Holy shit,
where I've always wanted to have track
suits for the whole band,
like when we're loading in because they
have to like do a lot of work.
But Let me be honest.
if you get a track suit,
don't you have to get adidas?
Keep call,
maybe bombs,
sign a little hip hop.
I'm slurring my words phone about you.
Play pool real good right now though,
right?
Let's fucking do this.
We played pool earlier and I did not
play my best,
but you know what was bizarre and just
beat joe so badly.
Maybe you weren't given us the full
juice.
We came down to it to games.
We just right down ball the ball,
but you played it so much better than
us.
Oh,
here we go.
she called me.
My god.
This is good night.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Honey.
Suzanne santo.
New album on August 11th.
No.
Yeah,
I'll bet you
it sounds like shit.
Hold on till it.
The audio quality's terrible.
It got compressed my sentence.
I texted it to myself.
Oh yeah.
That sounds like that shit was coming
out of a title so you know,
it could sound better than.
That sounds way better than I realized I
had to stop it.
I was like,
there's no way I could have that
represent that song.
There's no way to get it through a
computer.
You have to text it to yourself.
I'm trying to get it and it's not.
My phone is not connected to the
computer right now.
I don't know why or I can't.
Like he's.
He texted it to me.
It's to be complicated.
If jamie can't get at it was.
It was impressive.
Impressive.
Yeah.
That was a nice like feed myself and
that wouldn't,
would have been perfect song wasn't
attached in the email.
Lots of dIfferent things.
So there's no other way to get it.
Uh,
well don't you guys have a way that you
can tell people if someone says,
hey ben,
I heard your punk kid song is really
awesome.
Where can I go about hearing that?
I'll,
I'll let them know where is it,
where is it?
Then we did on soundcloud.
We can do that right before we got on
the podcast was like organize our social
media because our honey honey website
looks like our records just coming out
and it came out three years ago,
but we're working on that.
This is part of the diy conundrum.
It's also part of the promoting artists
conundrum because like the thing that
makes you a really good artists also
makes you shit at promoting.
It's hard.
It's a lot,
but that's what's cool about getting
teams around you like mess with you and
they get weird.
No,
no.
Honestly you having a as your thing.
Dude.
Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
I get this game changer for you guys.
Could figure out how to get one of your
favorite fucking song and play it shit.
I feel like it'S time to go barbecue
now.
We're defInitely going to a barbecue.
We're just gonna play the song.
Then we're going to barbecue.
What else to say?
Vegas this weekend,
friday night I'll be at the theater at
the mgm with tony hinchcliffe.
It's where they do the cirque to sell
how fun.
Little diaper and they connect to the
diaper and the climate.
A lot of money to see that.
No,
they have this crazy setup back there.
We don't use it.
We just use a flat stage but the setups
and go,
can I go fuck you it all these hydraulic
vegas.
What's your birthday weekend?
Oh shit,
this is your birthday weekend like
someone's going to vegas.
Someone needs to go to for for the
birthday.
Saturday night.
We're going to get the biggest.
It's going to be good scene.
We're going to make lots of money.
Oh,
you guys gamble.
so we have no solution so far.
this is insane.
Was such a.
I mean,
you know it gets compressed.
It shouldn't though.
Yeah.
The texting did if you can.
It wasn't attached to the email and I
tried to put my email in there so I
didn't a different route through email.
This is not going to work.
People wAnt to fight it.
Those hackers going to send jamie dick
pics all day.
Don't do it to him.
Come on.
You want to see it?
You could just forward them to me.
Have you gotten dick pics before?
Yeah,
definitely know when you get like
freely.
Well it depends on if I am into it or
not,
but there's a great dick pic,
which is the actual.
It's got dressed them up at the dicks
hats.
You ever see that one?
That do to turn this into a dragon and
he put tattoos all over his dick and
shit and that sounds awful.
Sharing the dragon dick joke and I'm
like,
yes,
I do.
Okay.
I'm going to send you a dick pic.
Nice.
Finally,
we've been friends a long time,
but I feel like it's about time.
It's time.
We limit threshold.
Really bump up.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh,
got solid.
Solid.
Here it is.
Okay.
That's about in line with the other
jokes.
Even threatened.
interesting.
I get it.
It's a a dick on a pic,
folks.
Joe,
just to make me feel bad.
I'm going to send you a dick pic.
No,
you don't have to make them all.
Have you seen the one with the guy who
was a football player or anyone you
know?
Should we end this?
I feel like we should just.
Oh,
it didn't.
It didn't get.
Oh,
sorry guys.
Did it go through.
I can play the one where they were on
here on the podcast.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
That we can do that.
Jamie really wants to play that one.
I feel like.
Well,
he knows it's a good audio quality.
Know where it is.
Yeah.
That.
Okay,
let's,
let's do that one.
Is it still daylight outside?
Uh,
yes.
He's still so apm now.
Oh my god.
I was shooting bows and arrows.
It's 7:45
the other day.
You were?
Yeah.
It was clear enough to the target.
You shoot them into the abyss.
Where do you shoot?
Your arrow is old unfortunate spots.
So I just sent it to you.
Okay.
Well,
how's that?
Gonna work.
Okay.
And you send it to jamie and it didn't
work because I don't have.
I mean that's what it's feeling like.
Hey,
did reach out to your lava lamps?
I'm just gonna say that right at school.
I feel entranced by the trying to go as
hippie as I can without being a hippie.
I get.
Okay.
Jamie has salt rock lamp.
I'm just going to say that that's got a
couple of those.
One of them died on us.
Yeah,
very sad.
Did it lose its positive ions?
That's a good question.
Uh,
I think it's just the power cable
crapped out.
That one's dead,
right?
Is that one not work anymore?
Yeah.
That one doesn't work with that one.
Works.
See that one is lit up and supposedly
it's a.
It's a good size.
This next tier marshall amp is that
marshall amp also as like a radio?
It's a bluetooth speaker.
One of those really badly.
Yeah.
We can have those sound great.
Do you want it?
It's yours.
You have it.
Got to clean this place out.
Anyway.
What can a new studio.
Okay,
I'll take it and I send it to jamie.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
We got this.
This August 7th.
Suzanne santos.
Pop punk kid knew he flashing your
tearing shit up.
I bet you a because it takes one to
know.
Yeah,
I'll bet you will
let you made your mouth good.
Yeah.
Oh,
you do.
We did it folks.